foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
a storm is brewing Dimitri on Jacob
Drake is a wizard within the Tempest the
best have come to test their skills and
brave the storm
oh we missed it oh
my goodness the wheels the wheels have
come out that could be the match for
some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness 98 whoa
what a tactic
this is insane oh look at Fabby
exhausting every last resource the
battles will be Electric
the moves will be fast it's game over
it's winning oh my God he's gonna make a
queen the stakes will be high he just
grabs his head he can't believe it he
just gave away the pawn the 2022 speed
Chess Championship is now
passenger speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
all right ladies and gentlemen we hope
your speed belts are fastened because we
have another incredibly exciting speed
Chess Championship matchup for you today
happy Monday everybody I'm your host
Grandmaster Daniel naritzki alongside me
today my good friend the legendary
Grandmaster Jeffrey Zhang JX welcome to
the show good afternoon how excited are
you to watch another Hikaru Nakamura
love honoronian matchup
good afternoon Donya good afternoon or
good evening to everybody out there in
chat yeah I am super excited to be here
I think there is no better way to start
off your week than to watch two
Gladiators like her and Lavon go at it
today
Gladiators is the perfect descriptor the
games will begin in just a couple of
minutes but first let's take care of a
couple very important pre-show items
first we need to ask what is at stake in
the speed Chess Championship the prize
pool a cool 100 G's the winner earns 4
000 with an additional 4 000 based on
win percentage and if you think wait
have the numbers changed they have
because we are now in the round of eight
both icaro and Lavon have won their
preliminary matchups so Jeffrey the
prizes are generous the participants are
incredible and I always say this they
don't need any more motivation but the
prizes are a nice additional bonus but
if you're playing Hikaru you're already
plenty motivated aren't you
oh for sure yeah everybody looking to
take down the Big Dot note as a car but
yeah I mean these prizes have certainly
jumped from where we started
um but I will say that I think these
players have both been around for quite
a while they've played at the highest of
stakes and they will just be looking to
play some good chess today
they will indeed let's take a quick look
at our overall bracket Lavon and Hikaru
neither of them had an easy preliminary
matchup Hikaru had the more commanding
victory over the qualifier David paravin
that's over on your top left and right
below Hikaru of honoronian wins by one
point that match against Dimitri on
Drake and was probably top three
fascinating SEC matches so far Jeffrey I
think will co-sign that point and the
other matches have been incredible as
well a very Stellar Victory by nihal
sarin in our last SEC matchup wherever
you turn Jeffrey we've just had amazing
action
truly I mean it has been crazy I think
you and I had the pleasure of calling
this knee-haul against Geary match that
went down to the wire obviously Levon
himself playing this epic Thriller where
he come came back in amazing fashion
against on Drake and so it's just been
amazing across the board and we're gonna
keep seeing that I hope
I'm quite sure that we will today's
matchup involves the Kara Nakamura the
number one seed who faces off against
Levon aronia now Levon not necessarily a
household name in online Blitz but that
victory over Dimitri on Drake and
definitely raised eyebrows and they're
Bullet Head to Head Hikaru holds a
commanding lead he holds a lead across
all quick time control splits uh full Ed
but notice that in the classical
head-to-head levonne aronian actually
holds a rather convincing lead Jeffrey
do you think Lavon is going to be
seeking some sort of Confidence from
their classical head-to-head score
that is certainly a thing however this
is unfortunately bullet and Blitz
entirely so I don't think akaro will be
worried about that record um by any
means and I also would like to point out
that if your name is not a certain
Magnus Carlsen uh Hikaru has never ever
lost a match in the SEC so that is
something you have to take account for
yeah you certainly do the extent of his
domination can hardly be overstated he
has won the last four editions of the
speed Chess Championship moreover if
anybody except Magnus defeatsukara that
will already just by definition
constitute one of the biggest upsets in
SCC history so Hikaru definitely has a
big X on his back okay let's talk
quickly about the format we remind you
that the speed Chess Championship is a
16 player knockout with many of the
players already having been knocked out
players cumulatively score points across
three-time controls until the overall
match time runs out in the event of a
tie we have a four game bullet
tiebreaker followed by an Armageddon if
that is tied and the three-time controls
which should already be ingrained in
your mind are 90 minutes of five plus
one the slowest time control followed by
an hour of three plus one and the match
concludes with half an hour 30 minutes
of bullet with a one second increment
and another thing Jeffrey I try to point
out before every match one plus one a
very different game from one plus zero
and that increment lavon's gonna be
holding on to it like you know someone
who's whose boat has capsized and
they're holding on to some Flotsam in
the sea you know he needs that increment
today doesn't he
he really does I mean Hikaru is just so
fast comes up with moves like at the
speed of lightning in those time
scrambles it doesn't feel like he ever
blunders either so really really gonna
be tough for a lot in that time control
but
the thing that I love about SCC it's
very balanced you can't specialize in a
particular time control uh you have to
be ready to go and all three of them you
also have to be ready to change the pace
balance things out so it's a really
great Dynamic that the format offers and
I'm looking forward to see how the
players handle it
it most certainly is well let's go over
the smarter chess and Community
predictions smarter chess has been
incredibly accurate thus far I have to
begrudgingly admit and smarter chess is
predicting an 85 percent win probability
for Hikaru I think that's pretty fair uh
he predicts that hikara will have a two
point lead after the five plus one and
will really carry the match away in the
following segment now obviously Lavon is
going to have to break the narrative
early if he wants to be competitive in
in this match and Jeffrey I really think
that the five plus one those 90 minutes
that's where Lavon really has to start
trying to uh counteract the smarter
chess narrative
I am totally with you I feel like the
five minute portion will really dictate
this match not only because I mean just
starting out Lavon wants to really make
Hikaru feel like you know he's here to
play he's here to fight hey Carl known
for his bullet prowess but I think
people often forget that he also knows
his way around the five minute and
longer time controls I do recall a
certain match that he had against the
big fish where he started it out with an
adoption so yeah I think if Lavon wants
any chance to to compete here he will
need to get off to a good start
yeah he definitely does and Hikaru just
has a way of pulling away from the match
very early I mean we'll talk more about
his previous match against David bravian
as the match gets underway the community
predicts 96 of those of you who filled
out a bracket and had this match in your
bracket predicted Hikaru Nakamura to win
with only four percent going for Hikaru
uh going for levonaroni in 287 to be
exact and 55 only 55 predicted this
matchup to happen and the reason why I
think is because a lot of you thought
that Dimitri and draken was going to go
a lot further in the SCC than he did but
that is going to be a storyline Jeffrey
that we're going to be talking about a
lot as this match gets underway the kind
of tendency of a lot of Chess fans to
underestimate players with whom they're
not quite as familiar and Lavon ronian I
think is one of them he showed in his
last match he can play Fast he has that
online chess skill set and Hikaru is not
looking at this as as a walkover I'm
pretty confident confident
yeah you do raise that point with the
bullet I think Lavon stunned not only on
Drake but many others with his ability
to manage those time scrambles uh in
that bullet segment I also recall a
niche uh stun Niha with his bullet
skills like he even made me eat my words
I thought uh nihal was going to be a
huge favorite in that but that it just
goes to show that I mean when it comes
to SEC don't uh expect anything and that
96 to 4 though I mean I can't seem to
get over it uh Lavon he's no slouch but
I guess it just goes to show how
dominant people know uh Hikaru is
yeah no that's definitely true and uh
the games are going to start very very
shortly another thing that has to be
pointed out in hikaru's match against
David paravian uh he started with A3 and
H3 and all sorts of offbeat openings
Jeffrey do you think we're gonna we're
gonna see him repeating that
for her for his sake uh I hope he
doesn't I think Lavon is the kind of guy
that if you want to fool around with him
he's gonna show you right to the door so
hopefully I mean I I won't say that the
approach to like sort of avoid your
opponent's breath is not a good idea I
think Hikaru might still try that but
not at the expense of uh starting out
with a 1h3 for example yeah I I
completely completely agree and I feel
like
um I I feel like LaVon is just going to
bring his A-game in terms of opening
preparation
but we'll see the games have started
Hikaru has the white pieces as the top
seed in game one and a knight F3 B3 so
as you predicted Jeffrey Hikaru going
much more mainstream at the start of the
match
yeah mainstream by his standards like I
wouldn't say 903 B3 uh is you're what
you see every day but for Hikaru that is
his system and Lavon should be uh should
be well prepared for it as well
yeah Knight C6 and now E3
by Hikaru so this is very standard Fair
the bishop usually comes out to B5 in
these lines but we've also seen Hikaru
play this uh with an early D4 but here
he goes Bishop B5 and you can almost
think of this as a reverse nimzo Indian
exactly it is uh
uh we I think we are going down that
path white often takes on C6 here plants
are down to E5 and supports it with F4
and I think we're gonna see that
yeah Knight comes to E5 D3 Knight D2 F4
you can rattle off a ton of easy moves
here which is why I think this is a very
practical opening for white and we we've
seen Hikaru play this you know almost
exclusively in the rapid Chess
Championship with a lot of success
right I do recall a few examples and
Hikaru basically he once give the bishop
pair but he has the stallion on E5 and a
lot of attacking potential with the
ideas with uh that we spoke about you
know F4 you often see a rook lifting up
to uh G3 and could be very dangerous if
Lavon doesn't uh play precisely
yeah for sure and we already see Lavon
taking a good chunk of time Bishop comes
out to D6
Knight D2 Hikaru responding almost
instantly and you normally don't rush
with Knight takes C6 in these types of
positions you try to keep the Knight on
E5 as long as possible the favorable
trade involves black taking on E5 that
gives white uncontested control of the
dark Square
in an early B5 push here from the Vaughn
looking to start something on the queen
side also perhaps giving the B7 Square
where his Bishop to drop back in and
Reserve that Bishop there
so very interesting moment I think
Hikaru could keep continuing with this
kingside play uh with the Rook of three
Rook G3 idea or you can react to lavon's
Queen side uh
uh pushes with the move C2 C4
yeah exactly I'm not sure if akara wants
Rook H3 Rook G3 you stay flexible with
both options uh meanwhile Lavon has to
really consider how does he deal with
this bind that Hikaru has in the center
do you want to play a typical 98 at F6
driving away that night or do you simply
want to keep going with your queen side
play
and
uh sorry but Donya I guess
has some mic issues so I will take over
for the moment
uh
yeah so Lavon here I'm calculating move
C4 just right now how do I sound now
diagonals
but I feel as if it doesn't accomplish
exactly what I want to
um at the rate I need I have to remove
let's say C4 Rook G3 there could be
Knight G4 so I'm trying to address the
problems
uh
more concretely here maybe a 98 move
with the drawback of that would be Rook
H3 and potentially Queen H5 so he does
play D4
opening up his Bishop on C6 but also
creating massive tension here in the
center
I think white will react by
maybe actually you have a few options
here you could take on C6 and D4
which would be a pawn up so perhaps
this could initiate some wild
complications
thinking after Knight C6 Rook C6 ed4
c84 Bishop D4 what is the Fallout there
potentially just a positional Pawn sec
Lavon might want Bishop B4 there
and playing for that week C3 Square very
very interesting stuff
um alternatively Hikaru could also move
his Rook to say G3
yeah and by the way I am back I
apologize I had some
audio issues but
um I know you've been doing a terrible
job as usual Jeffrey you know the layer
of your caliber can't really handle the
commentary yourself of course
so so D4 has just been played right by
Lavon
yes and I'm trying to understand first
of all what is lavon's idea if I simply
take on C6 and on D4
yeah that is a pawn isn't it and you
can't play Bishop F4 at the end because
the Rook captures and simultaneously
defends the bishop
right so I was thinking maybe Levon just
wants to play for positional
compensation and in the form of let's
say a bishop B4 move uh in that position
aha and basically play against the C2
Pawn
Bank on your control over the C3 Square
something like that
precisely and I assume that Hikaru has
to take the pawn now um Levon might also
be considering Knight D5 attackie on F4
and also bringing that Knight to a nice
Central post
yeah for sure and Lavon hesitating on C
takes D4
Yeah you mentioned Knight D5 he can play
the move immediately
but to me c takes D4 almost seems pretty
automatic
yeah I'm looking at this line uh deeper
with the CD4 Bishop D4 Bishop B4 and how
do you react for white because my idea
is once you move the bishop I'm going to
plant my Bishop on C3 and just say that
for the pawn I have
big compensation just in terms of uh my
pressure along the C and D files
yeah and he does play Knight D5 actually
interesting choice
uh-huh and what is this follow-up if I
just coolly protect my Pawn with let's
say G3
I guess then he'll place he takes D4
maybe stick a knight on C3 uh he wants
to Knight there okay the thing is like
in a Blitz game I'm worried about
lavon's compensation here because you
make one misstep white manages to get
his Pawn let's say to C4 and all of a
sudden the compensation evaporates but
the clock's coming really down to the
wire her D takes C5 why he car and I
think he's gonna follow up with D4
and if he could get a move C4 that would
solve all of his problems completely he
would have addressed that backward C
pawn and the pawns would get ruling
exactly C4 is on the horizon for Hikaru
I think the bishop has to drop back to
D6 to gain that Tempo against the F4
Pawn
absolutely that would seem to be the
case I mean if you allow C4 in your
knight would have to retreat that seems
to be heading in the wrong direction so
at least after Bishop D6 if white were
to react to the final four you play this
move B4 fixing that pawn on C2
oh that's a great move he plays Bishop
before and now in the event of C4 he's
planning bcbc and then Bishop takes D2
if we bring up an analysis board really
quickly I'll show the line C4 this is
important takes takes Bishop takes D2
and if you play C takes D5 looks like
white wins a piece but no black
recaptures on D5 and The Rook is under
Fire so you can't take the bishop you
drop the exchange good calculation there
Jeffrey bye Lavon I like Bishop before
that was Elite provocation he played
Bishop D6 to provoke G3 just so The Rook
is hanging in the line so very very deep
calculation in a subtlety shown by Lavon
and now the queen comes out to C7 I kind
of stand corrected I thought lavon's
initiative was going to be insufficient
now I feel like he's got at the very
least full compensation he's up on the
clock this is an early chance for Levon
as he triples on this I file now C2
hanging yes but Hikaru does have the
move C3 I believe
it is protected enough times
you do the counting
yes it is
there's like uh four Ps for each side
attacking on C3 but yeah besides C3
though I don't really see another
alternative wait ghost Rook F2 but I
thought now black can clamp down on the
C3 Square so put a knight on C3 you can
also put a knight on E3 but I'd be very
skeptical about that move it looks like
the Knight won't be able to get out of
C2
Queen A5 a different approach by Lavon
he hits the A2 Pawn actually
okay yes can you react with A3 with the
idea after Bishop through okay one
so I guess okay one black will play B4
yeah yeah well I go C4 there you allow
me this cheeky idea where you can't take
episode and I get rid of my backward C
Pawn oh that's a great move and now and
then the Rooks on the C file kind of
look dumb and Hikaru starts rolling in
the center Lavon definitely missed a
three
he drops his Bishop back to E7 now
Hikaru is making some progress Jeffrey
he's gonna put a knight on C5
indeed and while all White's pawns are
on dark squares which is definitely
concerning however a pawn is upon
a pawn is definitely a pawn and it just
seems like Black's initiative has
fizzled out just a little bit lavon's
best approach here is probably just to
play A6 and kind of sit on the position
he's so solid in the center but I'm
getting really worried as the clocks
really get down to 15 seconds here
who and he's got to move he-fi played on
the border car dropping below 15 seconds
so a very slow start for both players I
think he's got to start banging out
moves now and he does with that five and
he finds the right moment to open up the
king side things getting a little
dangerous here for Lavon
oh oh 13 seconds and counting yeah the
king side attack he's just starting to
show up around the king black is just
starting to crumble you can't play F6
because if Rook takes D5 and Knight
takes F6 LeBron out of five seconds he's
losing control of the position and there
might be D5 opening up the bishop also
that Rook on season should be loose oh
this is when Hikaru is just so lethal
you can't take the pawn with either
piece Lavon down to one second I think
he's dropping this one he Flags yeah
it's even close
yeah I mean once both players had to
start turning on the Jets it was just
hit car who intuitively feels the Right
Moves and that D5 move came with
authority
wasn't it insane how quickly it went
from okay black is down a pawn and
Incredibly solid the moment Hikaru
played F5 I could sense that Levon was
losing control
yeah indeed and as Alex is saying in the
chat never let the game go to 10 saying
each versus otherwise you are doomed as
we just saw
yeah that was absolutely insane and the
thing is the problem
for Love on is that if things ever if
things get down to Any Time scramble 10
seconds against 10 seconds Hikaru is
going to win 95 of the time let's let's
be real so Lavon just has to try to take
the game into middle games where both
players have time he can't let it get
down to these tactical scrambles
for sure I don't think he can I mean he
did show
some really nice technique and form
um low on the clock against on draken
but it or just
this is the world's Elite I mean it's a
whole nother animal
and at this time we have a rather tame
tame English opening
this system with Knight T4 that has been
popular for for a while now
and hard to make specific observations I
think the position is approximately
equal maybe white has a small pole here
he's got better control over the center
but ikaro more than happy to get these
these long drawn out positional middle
games I think that's his approach in the
early going of the match
indeed and this idea Knight C6 Knight D4
um first of all yeah I guess you trade
Knights but the main idea is to free
that c pawn and later I believe Hikaru
will follow it up with a C6 and perhaps
even D5 to fight for the center
yep
and the bishop does drop down to C5
c65 is possible you can also just play
D6 so white of course has this typical
idea of preparing b2b4 and expanding on
the queen side
but Lavon again he's just taking a lot
of time here in the early middle game
and I don't think that's setting him
setting him up for success
it does concern me and I do remember
playing these matches myself there were
always some nerves and uncertainty to
begin the match
and I feel like yeah he's gonna try he
needs to try his best to get some sort
of Rhythm and Pace going because
dropping one minute on uh down on the
clock instant car was a recipe for
disaster
for sure for sure and he continues to
think
what is he thinking about Jeffrey I mean
I would cat honestly and I'm actually
driving here big time but Castle's King
side seems pretty automatic maybe he's
attracted to the idea of Bishop G5 and
then trading it off on F6 and going 94.
he goes through could be one but and
pretty major sunk cost effect there that
move could have been played in 30
seconds honestly yeah and I feel like
it could be just him trying to be a
little bit too perfect but we have to
understand this is Blitz after all the
move that you make now is not going to
determine
the outcome of the game so you just
choose between three good ideas and I
mean trust your instinct
yeah keep talking Jeffrey I briefly
stopped stops hearing you
ah okay yes now I hear you again oh okay
perfect
so I mean a curve does need to address
this B4 B5 idea expanding on the queen
side
um you can go with C6 like I mentioned
you could also play D6 but yeah
ultimately deciding or C6
yeah and B4 is going to follow very
likely before we're going to see a trade
no Hikaru drops back immediately to E7
and am I okay I guess the point is that
B5 drops the A3 Pawn these little
details are Hikaru is so good at
seamlessly weaving them into his play
and we take them for granted like you
can't play B5 how do you fix that issue
maybe Queen B3 but that's going to take
more time off your clock
right and a car understands that it's up
to him when he wants to open the a file
so he's keeping flexibility and now I
think he's ready for D5
he most certainly is and I think after
D5 lavon's gonna have to try to put
pressure on that pawn maybe D5 Queen B3
okay Hikaru trades first just looks like
black is a great position here
he does I mean it seems like he saw a
lot of his problems he's about to
develop his final piece uh on the back
rink uh with the bishop on C8 but now
I'm starting to wonder can Levon play
the move B4 B5 and sort of undermine
that whole structure there
yeah B5 and then you want to take on C6
stake on D5 and go for example Bishop G5
if we bring up an analysis board real
fast I just want to show what is at
stake in this position if black dilly
dally is for even a move let's say black
plays Bishop B6 which is actually a
pretty decent looking move what white
wants here is to take on C6 take on D5
and then go Bishop G5 and you know if
you kind of Sleepwalk into a position
like this White's got Rook B5 white
Scott Queen B3
and things get really really unpleasant
here don't they
absolutely they do that D5 Pawn
surprisingly weakness and lavon's going
to start by taking on D5 maybe a similar
idea and he feels that you can play
Bishop G5 immediately
and Bishop G5 is played on the board
attacking D5 indirectly Bishop B6
and of course the immediate Queen D3
runs into D4 and white drops a knight so
everything seems pretty well defended
here for the time being Lavon down to a
minute I'm honestly more worried about
that a lot more work than I am about the
position on the board
I mean yeah they're on a full almost
three minutes on the clock this is
unacceptable um I'm thinking of Bishop
F6 yeah E4 and planning that Nano D5 at
least you play opposite colored Bishops
and this should be
uh easier to navigate I would say with
load time but I mean certainly just too
slow out of the gates
and E4 is a good move I think D4 Knight
D5 is the idea
and I guess the car should maybe take on
e4 and keep the position as open as
possible with the two Bishops
that was a logical approach but Carl's
gonna lock it up anyway after Knight D5
I don't think he intends on removing
that Knight I think he wants to cling on
to his Bishop here maybe it moves like
Bishop G5 which would prevent White's
Rooks from occupying the CFL and black
could be the one pressing there in the
near future instead he goes Bishop back
to E7 I've seen a lot of games uh I've
seen white lose a lot of games in the
English like this so let's say there's a
trade that happens black just sticks a
rook on C3 and if black wins this game I
think it'll have something to do with
the C3 Outpost and with the D3 Pawn
oh yeah and I think it would also have
something to do with Lavon sinking below
40 seconds played Rook A1 he's trying to
simplify as much as he can because he
knows that the more pieces you keep at
the end it's going to be really
difficult not to blunder uh when it's
time to get short
yeah okay one
so Lavon basically saying here take my
Pawn Hikaru says no I want to keep
pieces on the board of course he can
take on D5 take on B4 at any moment I
think he will do that with all of the
Rooks on the board
yes at some point and that's why Lavon
oh he takes on E7 but positionally
speaking this is what you were
illustrating at least he plays Bishop G4
though to trade off his bad Bishop
so takes takes before and does Levon
have realistic drawing chances in that
position
I think so because he's he's getting a
few tempos maybe with Rook B1
potentially Rook C1 and at least
he ah actually I mean the more I look at
it where is the compensation though and
Hikaru doesn't even take the pawn he
says I don't care about before I care
about the C3 Square because if the D3
Pawn Falls then the game is over if
Hikaru occupies the C file you know the
communication between White's pieces is
broken I love Rook A5 though by Levon
he's not just folding over and dying
here
Rook A5 a critical resource here
counter-attacking on that E5 pawn and
also you could put the Rook on B5 where
it would not only be supporting the B
pump but attacking both B7 and E5
I think he's going to do just that right
now we have some play going on in the
king side H4 Lavon and H yeah H5 met
with Queen G5 I think ah and you can't
play F6 there because G6 Falls
Rook B5 you called it eval bar not a big
fan of that move though
I don't see why I mean for white the
next move is just to play H5 and I don't
see how black like you've got pressure
on D3 but can you increase it
yeah H5 Queen G5 Queen C7 maybe you kind
of just shuffle your heavy pieces over
and try to milk while it's clock down to
10 seconds
we're not really seeing it so far
yeah Rook B3 does attack on B4
so now you can take the pawn but it's
the idea to
oh he's going Rook D5
I thought he would take and go H6 and
try to create long-term problems against
black Singh instead Levon tries to keep
all the pieces on the board which makes
sense actually I mean he's getting
really active here
I do like flicking in that H6 move at
some point in saying to Black what are
you gonna do about your back ring
exactly it's not easy to push the beep
on here there's tons of logistical
issues Queen D7 could come at some point
and it's a pretty easy position to Blitz
out moves in isn't it for Lavon
it is yeah King G2 probably Rook d7x I
do like the king G7 move by Hikaru
though prophylaxis against H6 and now at
least it doesn't have to worry about
those back rink ideas
yep and now hecaro's clock running down
he's below a minute
and will he try to push B5 will he try
to squeeze that move in despite the
scary appearance of a move like Queen D7
maybe he'll play Queen E6 here try to
get the Queens off the board
many options yeah I I do think black can
get away with just pushing the B Pawn
maybe you start with the move like Rook
B1 and you start pushing
yeah I like Rook B1 kind of an
open-ended move and you're also creating
a potential precedent for you know a
queen appearing on soon whoa King H6
car using his King
trying to relieve some of the tension
there uh lavage simply ignores it so if
gh5 I guess he didn't like Queen D7 but
anyway we might see an ending here only
five seconds
he should be fine here I think it's
enough car to play these room enough but
Rook B2 Rook B2 Jeffrey oh no that's
gonna be a nasty move to face
oh
I'm running up with the king I think you
can take on G6 here King G5 oh why do
you allow kh5 I thought King G5 was just
Checkmate now Lavon is still in it
but he must be lost here Rook H2 okay he
takes it
no Rook Rook D2 is winning for black
yeah even this you just tie white down
completely and now the pawn is simply
full no White's down a pawn and and the
king is too passive there's no way he's
holding this
just take it
yep yeah I mean I feel like LaVon will
have to regret that those early moments
where he sunk into thought I mean these
next two games has got to make an
adjustment there in terms of the clock
and the game here not totally over just
yet hikara being very Levon being very
resilient but his King is cut off
there's nothing D2 D2 ends it
oh maybe not yet Hikaru being a little
bit sloppy there Jeffrey yeah I don't
think he should have gotten this no but
the good news for him is that Lavon is a
human on engine I know that the engines
defend these Queen and Rook until the
cows go home but for a human you just
won't be able to find the right squares
for your Rook that's a great way to put
it what Hikaru has to avoid are these
stale Matrix or what gives The Rook away
and you're forced to capture it and your
king is still made it so here you need
to be careful LeBron's lavon's down to a
second there's just no way there's just
no way
no right there
can you surrender what there is rookie
three there with this
oh not yet Rook C2
holy smokes the car was struggling here
oh he's gonna flag
oh man
yeah I don't think he found the way but
it was just too tough like wherever you
put your rookie might blunder it may or
or The Rook itself
that's just crazy and you're right I
mean those early
minute that minute he spent on on the
Move Rook V1 it was just a matter of
time he defended excellently but
Jeffrey we just know that Hikaru is
going to keep finding chances and keep
putting you in a position where you're
likely to make a mistake until you do
and it's largely a matter of time before
you do
it really is what he does best I mean
just the way he mounts the pressure he
keeps the pressure on you where the just
the whole game and that's why you need
time to deal with all of those little
tricks
and in this game Hikaru playing 2b4 not
a mouse slip I mean we've seen him
play that kind of move before we have an
exchange of the B4 Pawn for the E5 Pawn
according to Theory black should be
slightly better in these positions but I
feel like evaluation just mean nothing
when Hikaru is playing
it does feel like that doesn't it and
yeah the b445 pawn exchange is something
that was featured in the match against
baravion I had to call there and yeah
perovian did seem to be getting these
sorts of missions where you had the open
e-file for his Rook but Hikaru just
simply said look I have more control of
the center easy play for my pieces and I
think I have to move like C4 he's going
to be quite happy here yep C4 he's got
the B file Rook B1 could come at An
Inconvenient moment to pressure the pawn
on B7
and itsu can be easily protected with
either Rook E1 he can also play E3 but
that move seems a little bit a little
bit dicey weakening the D3 Pawn like
that
yeah I like simply rookie one here I
think you just hold the structure no
reason to weaken the diagonal and at
some point yeah we're going to see a
rook B1 we might see a G4 at some point
that black has to be aware of
so lots of flexibility I think for a car
in this position absolutely he's taking
some time
trying to figure out the best way to
protect E2
is there an alternative to rookie one
and E3 you mentioned E4
I wonder if he's considering throwing in
C takes D5 no but he plays E3
yeah surprising exactly what is he gonna
do here
yeah the D3 Pawn is loose like if you
were to protect with Queen C2 then maybe
bishop G6 would come immediately
and you might have to make a move you
don't really want to
and if you play Queen E2
then you're still pinned black can still
go Bishop G6 and if you have to play a
move like Knight F3 to E1 it's not the
end of the world but ikaro must have a
concrete idea here there it is
takes takes in D4 I think
um this is very clever yeah because you
didn't want to play D4 Lucky in your own
Bishop so first he takes on F6 and now
yeah I must say the structure
is good for white after cd5 D4 because
black would be left with isolated d-pawn
and white and address the pin with G4
um at its at his convenience and there's
also in the mix the the very unpleasant
move Queen T1 and B3 obviously not with
a knight on C5 uh but after D4 the
Knight moves in Queen B3 basically Forks
these two pawns this is an incredible
positional decision from Nakamura giving
up the bishop which sounds so
counter-intuitive but he knows he's
gonna go D4 and he's gonna play against
that weak isolated Pawn on D5 Lavon
might be contemplating
getting crazy with Knight takes D3 and
he does
I think this is a great practical
decision you might drop a pawn here
somehow but at least you keep the
position open for your Bishop pair
Queen comes out to A4 threatening the
pawn threatening Knight E4 Levon has to
tread very carefully another very nice
move I love this queen
and also I think he's tying down the
White Knight because neither of them can
move and release the protection of the
other night
exactly can't go Knight D4
can't go Knight C4 you can go G4 and
free up the D2 Knight but where is that
Knight going to go
maybe okay it's gonna play Rook B1 first
so now I guess I mean A5 rookie looks
natural but maybe Karen tends to play A3
and kick that Bishop
I think he does want to play A3
now there's a weird idea Bishop takes D2
and Bishop E2 but then icar will grab C6
with a counter Fork
yeah that would have been interesting
but look at this idea from LeBron 195
and that Queen is gonna have to
relinquish control of the A3 pawn and it
has nowhere good to go if we pull up an
analysis board Queen C2 might be forced
walking into Bishop to G6 because this
loses a piece Bishop takes D2 and if
Queen takes D2 you drop the Knight on F3
and Hikaru is going for this
and oh he's gone G4 Intermezzo but
that's gotta be bad
if we go back
at the very least Levon is Jason G6
winning exchange Hikaru loses a pure
exchange for no comp I mean the only
compensation is the strong light squared
Bishop this is a big sequence for Lavon
he has to cash this in has to
oh I mean he really does and
Robert Hess our good friend loves to
mention those backward night moves can
be so pesky and hard to anticipate that
Knight C5 for sure did escaped hikaru's
attention for a second but we already
know and we've discussed so many times
sicaro's
magician-like ability to get out of
these
positions that most people would lose
without much of a fight and I already
like the way this is going for him the
Queens are off the board but he's gonna
win C6 and his minor pieces are pretty
well positioned to mount a serious
resistance
yeah now you don't necessarily want to
take on C6 right away I don't think
because then the black Rooks would come
into action the move like Rook AC 8 and
that's exactly what you want when you're
up in exchange is open files to operate
and an exchange of Rooks you called it
Rook to C3 and F4
might be likely no Hikaru just says I'm
not in a hurry to pick up that pawn
you're right he doesn't want the C file
to open prematurely
and he might transfer that Knight to the
very solid Central Square of D4 and at
his own Leisure will he pick up that C6
Pawn eventually with uh with an F4 and
he could choose which piece to take C6
with
Lavon shifting is Rook to an open file
and
as you predicted the Knight lands on D4
wait a minute Rook C5
yes he would have Knight D3 there enough
to Rook A5 C5 the C punt would be Mighty
fast down the board C5 is actually a
huge threat here let's see what Hikaru
can bring to the table maybe Knight D3
Rook back to C3 try to play it against
the Knight ah but I do I have C5
anywhere there's Knight C6 so it could
get confusing but akaro choosing simply
to take on the sticks and stuff oh and
this is so smart because if you trade
Rooks the Knight recaptures and you
can't defend A5 Rook A8 would have run
into a discovery with 97 check now
Hikaru has a chance to keep the Rooks on
the board if he wants but that would
allow a very nasty backrank check on C1
mm-hmm I think this last move extremely
classy by Lavon G6 not only do you
create Luft but you also stop in a
potential Knight F5 from landing on the
board and as you said there is no Rook
A6 so the car just has to trade Rooks
here
but Knight C6 does win the A5 fund I
think Hikaru is on the road
to drawing this game obviously a497 is
not what black wants
so if black were to react with King G7
you take on A5 do you think I can drop
enough play with with like a rook C1 or
Rook C2
and you're you're speaking the right
language here you have to drum up that
play before the night re-enters the game
I think if Hikaru can get his Knight
back around to the civilization
his drawing chances will be the highest
they've been since he lost that Exchange
yeah exactly I think this is a very
critical moment for Lavon how best to
make use of this extra exchange if
rookie won Bishop one I don't see the
Flop so he's gonna go Rook C3 just win
back that a pawn which I don't think he
Oro can hang on to no and he probably
should he should probably go Knight C6
Knight T4
he does try to hang on to it for the
time but he's doing it more to win some
Tempe he's not actually I think so he's
not actually going to try to keep he
can't keep this Pawn
no you simply can't um after okay three
where do you think he should position
the Knight um there's a car
well D4 was my initial idea but maybe
the Knight on D4 is no longer that
relevant
okay Knight B2 LeBron
maybe keeping alive some hopes of Rook
C1 Knight I don't know how exactly he's
trying to shuffle his his pieces around
yeah say Cora I'm looking for the right
configuration to best and give me the
best Fortress as possible he's gonna
he's really holding on to that EPO well
what he's saying is hey I'm gonna give
you that a pawn but you're gonna have to
allow me to exchange a pair of minor
pieces and if the bishop is exchanged
for the night Jeffrey Knight and four
against rook and three is basically a
dead drop
isn't it yes it is and I think I'm
trying to figure out if Rook against
Bishop would offer better chances for
Levant but it's hard to say looks like
we are going to see The Rook against now
I don't think he's winning this I mean
there are chances but he cars should
take on A4 put the Knight on D4 and
chill
and that's exactly what he's going to do
assume Knight F3
yeah this this you could call this a
fortress but it's more just that like
black doesn't have any Targets to attack
I guess that is a fortress lavon's gonna
try though he's gonna try to get his
king or onto E1 and Jeffrey like it is
very possible to lose this game or he
car he has to defend very carefully he
has to be able to give the right Knight
check at the right time and keep his
King on a good Square so a lot of moving
Parts here for white oh yeah plenty of
work to do defensively for Hikaru the
one good thing is that if Black's King
Ventures too far I feel like white will
always have a way to get counter play on
that F7 point
so that's why I don't believe it'll be
so easy for Lavon just to bring his King
up
hicaro kind of going bunker style and he
pushes up the pawn he wants to go H5 and
carve out a weakness on F5
also Pawn trades generally favor white
here but King E1 is a huge threat now
yeah that would tie wide down to the
defensive F2 so he's gotta oh but this
should work like you after key one you
leave your 94 and I think that's
unpenetrable so Lavon keeps the pawns on
the board
Hikaru very close to a fortress but but
Jeffrey 94 there's always going to be
this Rook A4 move and Icarus created
another big weakness for himself on H4
that is a good point Oh I thought do I
have F3 here and then with some Knight
D6 ideas
yeah Lavon could lose this if he
overpresses if he loses F7 and G6
suddenly your car is gonna have a
thousand past Pawns
this is crazy how do you win this record
down to 30 things but Lavon lavon's I'm
ticking down now and here we go with
this again all three games have gone
down to time scrambles can Lavon keep
his composure he brings the Rook back to
Asics to stop Knight D6 but he car is
going to keep jumping around
very important and it's so easy to panic
here when white is gonna you know prance
around with that night if you allow it
to attack on F7 you might not have a
defense E5 could come it's minus five
but forget the evil Bar for a second
it's down to the wire Rook D4 check Rook
D4 is huge make a move he's down to one
second
five oh it's still sharp and this is a
three result game
but Lavon should win this
oh is winning okay he's gonna win H4 I
know that at least he can't lose this
but Hikaru has a big way to take H5 I
don't think he should have given that
away
it is winning wow and it's just made oh
and this
wow what a wonderful job there
wonderful job by Lavon keep his nerves
we should definitely pull that game up
and show
[Laughter]
game uh that is not the last game
they pull up the uh the previous game as
the next one gets underway
um insane insane I actually think that
Hikaru might have had a draw
apparently Jeffrey with a crazy move
Knight to E6 here that was the engine
move giving up H4 but I guess you bank
so the idea is that after G6 the reason
you put the Knight specifically here is
to be able to intercept the G file with
my G5 check
I mean good luck finding that with five
seconds yeah so both sides promote and
it's kind of a 50 50 position but
obviously Lavon did everything he had to
do to win that game and the decision
to push his e-pawn and give up the other
pawns was actually an incredibly wise
one this is losing your car not fast
enough wow
and that is a very very good sign for
Lavon
um just I mean the way he kept his
converter there down to seconds we saw
it a lot in on drinking I wasn't sure if
he could repeat that today but that is a
very good good sign there
okay so on we go to the next game this
is the last game before the halftime
break
and we have a a Bishop's opening which
is another line that Hikaru has been
playing with white this time he's on the
black side
and I'm not too impressed with what
Lavon has so far what do you make of
this
yeah certainly are very well versed for
this uh having experience on both sides
I guess lavon's concept is that his uh
D5 gives him some space so like I assume
he's gonna go D4 at some point recapture
that with the Knight and say that okay I
understand it's symmetrical but my Pawn
on D5 just offering that slight space
Advantage okay I mean I have some
chances
yes yeah D4 it seems to be seems to be
pretty uh necessary here because if you
don't play it if you procrastinate then
you're going to end up with this
ugly Pawn mass in the center and black
can actually go Bishop G4 to prevent
white from recapturing on D4 with the
Knight
right exactly it could be now or never
here um the other big point that I will
say is after d484 Knight D4 the bishop
on C8 does lack developing squares is
your cutoff from the G4 Square you're
cut off from F5 and D7 albeit solid is
still a bit passive
why could us consider Queen to D3 here
to prevent the knight from coming out to
F5 which I think is what Nakamura wants
given that he lacks some space here
let's see how Lavon keeps squeezing
maybe a tiny Edge out of this position
yeah he is gonna allow Knight F5 but
then after Knight F5 and Bishop C5 maybe
he wants to say that are you really so
sure about your double C Pawn soakaro
again dealing away that Bishop but I
guess he's following it up with Knight
F5 yeah very concrete idea Bishop takes
D4 Knight F5 and lavon's Bishop pair is
going to be short-lived
and a draw here would be I think a good
result for Hikaru just kind of
stabilizing after that loss
and yeah might have five coming looks
pretty solid for black
it does but I've seen Magnus uh squeeze
these kinds of positions out in a Berlin
like a bishop F1 Berlin resembles this
type of thing
so yeah I'm gonna see what uh what Lavon
has in store maybe at some point he'll
double the Rooks or swing uh swing some
Brooks we'll see
he also has the long-term idea of kind
of King's Indian style pushing C4 C5
launching a queen Side Pawn attack but
but the problem is that with that open
e-file I feel like Hikaru is going to be
able to get the Rooks off the board
faster than white will be able to create
serious play on the queen size so let's
see how this unfolds obviously Lavon
holds all of the cards here he's I
wouldn't say playing for two results but
it's a pleasant position for sure
very pleasant and that move F3 a slight
connection of certain maybe Ben Feingold
frowning at that move but it does Force
black take on D4 and now with the queen
on D4 you tie down the Rook to uh on a
to the defense of that A7 Pawn which
could be annoying
so rookie eight Caro offering the trade
of Rooks and again his goal given that
he lack space is to get all the heavy
pieces off the board he doesn't have any
Targets so a bishop end game would be
pretty much a dead draw here
yeah indeed you simply yeah you just
wouldn't have any weaknesses to exploit
the bishop D3 is going to play it slow
maybe he has your idea in mind of the
c4b4 C5
I think he does I think he's also
thinking about a later Queen E4 maybe
when the Rooks are off the board
and Hikaru I've seen this idea before of
like Rook takes C1 and then Queen f8 to
make space for the other Rook to come in
but Hikaru plays this more actively with
Queen G5 I like that move that's a good
move
yeah not only do you connect the Rooks
but you have this sneaky little idea of
entering White's camp with Queen D2
although the moment I say that I
realized there's Bishop H7 oops
so uh yeah I've gotta be more careful
but what about Queen to G3 what is Lavon
planning there
uh maybe he wants just an end game I see
him slightly shaking his head perhaps
uh forgetting about that move but yeah I
mean the end game perhaps a little bit
too dry uh to really hope for chances
also Queen F4 knowing Hikaru if you
Michael queen of four and say wait a
second you've made a lot of weaknesses
on the king side I'm gonna start
thinking about playing for a win here
yeah certainly an option I'm not sure
which one you'll go for
as black
as soon as you play the moves like B6
and A5 just consolidating the entire
Queen set on dark squares I think you
simply don't have any chance of losing
this game
oh totally and Hikaru says hey I'm up a
minute I've got active pieces
I'm Gonna Keep the Queens on the board
Lavon really kind of stretching himself
thin on the king side but for the time
being you know everything's still well
protected I still think the game is very
likely to end in a draw
yeah I'm in agreement I think we could
see the Rooks being traded because Queen
D4 which is a very interesting move
taking advantage of the fact that black
just pushed his Pawn to B6 so if you
were to take on D4 CD4 there is this
hole on C6 which white can exploit
that's a super kind of classic GM move I
think a lot of people would reject it
because of the double d-pawns but the
weakness on C7 as you said far outweighs
the sort of visual defects of white
spawn structure neither d-pawn will be
really possible to attack in that end
game so Hikaru needs to react because
Queen takes F6 will [__] Black's King
side pawns maybe rookie five
can be considered here putting a rook
between the Queens
what do you think yeah I I am wondering
about that move as well and trying to
understand the structure after a rookie
five but I was curious about this too so
Queen D40 ah I thought he was going to
play C5 and immediately address the C
Pawn
instead he plays A6 what's the idea to
play Bishop to B5
and is he not worried about a c Pawn
he's gonna put his Rook on A7 that's the
idea yeah but you say it like uh it's a
great thing but I'm not sure about the
looks of it
but it's solid and Hikaru is saying
you're not entering my position here
and maybe he'll follow up with Bishop to
B5
but lavon's gonna probably keep the
Bishops on the board
I think for sure he will and he's just
got a free hand here like The Rook on H7
is going to be stuck there for the
remainder of the game and meanwhile
Levon can do what he wants on the king
so just expanding there
and he does indeed he pushes the F1 up
he's trying to create a second Target on
the king side which he'll be well
equipped to attack that Rook on A7 has
seen better days
to put it mildly yeah and here I just I
like Bishop B1 simply keeping the
material on you have F5 in your back
pocket I don't think black can ever get
around to that D5 Pawn so it looks
really nice for for Lavon
but Hikaru kind of just sitting and
preventing F5 and if you're not playing
F5
then what are you doing because the king
can't enter a Black's position there are
no there's no pathway into Black's
territory here which is a problem for
Lavon
well at some point I am in a launch with
F5 so maybe I start with Bishop B1 if
it's my turn as white and then I'll play
F5 sacking upon temporarily but I regain
It On Media with king of four lovely
idea very instructive and I think he's
doing just that Bishop D3
and F5 coming to a theater near you
I think on the next move
yeah I'm really surprised at how quickly
Hikaru was willing to you know just put
his Rook on A7 and defend this
now if we take the opposite perspective
after F5 G takes F5 King F4
yeah black just liquidate the rest of
the king side with F6
ah that it's still still speculative I
feel like even if you liquidate my king
is so active and I have ideas of you
know
penetrating further but lavani's going
to hold off on that idea again he
doesn't really need to rush black just
sitting tight right now Lavon trying to
milk your car was clocked down because
every move is it takes a lot of energy
to play for black he has a lot to watch
out for
eign
so he reshuffles his Rook to C8 a
slightly better Square I think because
now C6 is in the mix if white moves the
bishop away but it's not as secure like
imagine a bishop appearing on that
diagonal it would instantly drive your
Rook away although now Hikaru has the
pawn F5 so I'm not sure if there's going
to be a break is it a fortress that's
the question it very well might be a
fortress the king is very well capable
of meeting of of Defending H7 and E7 it
just shuffles between F7 and G7
depending on where White's Rook goes
yeah now Carl gets to work on E7 so
that's perfect
yeah I think he solved his problems here
yeah once he gets the Rook to E7 I think
that's basically all she wrote in terms
of White's winning attempts here
yeah agreed I feel like LaVon could have
done a bit better but a draw certainly a
reasonable result you get it go into the
first break down a point that's
absolutely fine yeah winning these types
of end games against Hikaru I mean we I
think Magnus is maybe the only person
who can do it with any kind of
regularity
and this is just a dead draw no
breakthroughs
and they're going to find a repetition
here
well I don't know if you caught us some
certain moments in the uh last recorder
match where you had against peruvium but
when we got into this sort of dead drop
sessions he did show a tendency to waste
time although here he does give the draw
yeah and I
bigger lead or the match was further
Advanced I think in the three minute
portion we're gonna see Hikaru pulling
out all sorts of gamesmanship to milk
the clock down but in any case we have
reached the halfway point of the five
minute portion Jeffrey a one-point lead
for Hikaru he's got to be happy with the
result but I think Lavon is happy with
the trend of the match I think he's
happy to have scored that comeback win
it you know nothing has been decided yet
right
oh no no we're still in our early phases
of this match I think if Lavon just
improves his rhythm and get eases
himself into this match there could be a
lot of potential for him coming up so we
will see that on the other side of the
break we will see indeed as Lavon will
have the black pieces in the next game
but first the players are going to take
a short breather
uh so ladies and gentlemen you are
watching the speed Chess Championship uh
it's been a fascinating match so far and
Hikaru Nakamura will continue facing
levonaronian on the other side of this
short break we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
first approached me with the idea of
teaching children to play chess I
thought you want to do what
whatever you want to do
but how are you gonna do that and the
more we talked about it the more he laid
out the plan we tried some things and 15
years later we have fabulous program
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back ladies and gentlemen too
the speed Chess Championship 45 minutes
in
two Hikaru nakamura's round of eight
match against Lavon aronia GM Daniel
nerdinski GM Jeffrey Zhang chopping it
up for you today it's been a pleasure
commentating this uh long-awaited match
Jeffrey it's been close the score is two
and a half one and a half as we pull up
the chess.com Blitz insights
what catches you right here what's
caught your eye so far in this match
yeah it has been back and forth it was a
quick burst by a car 2-0 it looked very
concerning but Lavon able to sort of
right the ship with that third game yeah
move to a one point gap so a lot of
Chesapeake played in The Blitz insights
I mean it's hard not to be rocked by
that first statistic there 30 000 games
100 I live on damn girl I I don't even
want to count you know how much percent
above you know lavon's game that is I'm
sure the statisticians in the chat are
having a field day their average
accuracy similar uh obviously hikaru's
win percentage is absolutely ridiculous
Jeffrey I mean 13 loss is 77 wins I mean
are you kidding me
yeah and merely and I wanted to say also
at the very end 54 losses by Flag by
Levon I mean if you lose half your games
like that it does raise some sort of
alarm Bells but I think he's gotten a
lot better with his bullet skills in
handling those time scrambles he has and
a lot of players have which has been so
fun to watch players have adapted to
this new online chess ecosystem but in
any case the next game is underway
Hikaru uh s saying a a Kali system which
has been which has been around for well
over 100 years it's kind of the inferior
cousin to the London system except I
don't really consider it an inferior
cause and I think it's a more like a
brother
that would be a fair way to describe it
yeah I mean the main difference here is
you don't put your Bishop out but you
keep other flexible options and here
Hikaru is content with just transposing
this into like a qga with colors
reversed but I think he's gonna say that
okay I get it quick B for Bishop E2 and
then I'm happy
but I think Lavon is happy as well he
takes on C4 an early end game
you know set your alarms for five
minutes later let's wait for this to get
interesting I always feel like I have a
hard time evaluating Jeffrey weather
White space advantage on the queen side
is a good thing or a bad thing it's
inherently a good thing but you we're
also creating kind of a Swiss cheese
situation on some of the light squares
true it is very tricky especially when
you get hit with like an a7a5 for black
how do you react to this because if you
push B5 then a knight could suddenly
plant itself on the C5 Square so yeah
certainly tricky business
um but both sides handling it pretty
reasonably here key to nice to see uh
Hikaru put that key in the center there
in the end game
you could bring his Rook either Rook to
C1
maybe Rook ac1 Rook HD one that's the
conventional way of positioning your
towers and Lavon likely to do the same
thing you mentioned the C5 Square black
to try to provoke the weakness of that
score with a7a5 a very traditional idea
in these uh Queen's gamut accepted end
games
right exactly and for sure he'll be
considering that honest X move one thing
you have to evaluate though is after
a5b5 white is going to try and fight for
that C6 square and maybe say like okay
I'll give you C5 squared but
and you deal with a potential Knight
landing on C6 and what is sort of the
fight for for those two key squares
there
yeah that's a that's a very interesting
point that the night landing on C6 can
be far more destructive than a black
knight ensconcing itself on C5 so Rook H
to C1 by Hikaru I think a lot of people
in the chat are probably wondering why
he didn't put the other Rook on C1 and
Jeffrey that is one of the hardest
questions in chess which Rook to put on
a certain score we've all struggled with
it oh my God yeah tell me about it but I
think in this scenario the reason why I
want to put the Rook on A1 is he might
be anticipating that potential A5 and
once your B Pawn moves the A3 Pawn Could
lack protection so he wants to keep the
Rook on A1 supporting it great point I
totally agree with that take Lavon
playing it pretty conservatively with 98
to two ideas are possible Bishop F6
get the dark squared Bishops off and
maneuver the Knight around to D6 maybe
try to knock the bishop off this
diagonal and later on you could throw in
an unpleasant check on A6
oh yeah indeed A really lovely idea
typical in the qga and at some point
let's say uh White makes move black
plays Knight D6 you drop back with the
bishop on D3 there is this idea of F6 E5
that exists taking control of the center
and also blunting that white Bishop on
B2
that's a great point I think that's
worthy of showing on the analysis board
so let's pull that up let's say white
plays you know not entirely unlikely
that like this will happen but after
Knight D6 as sicaro putting his Knight
on B3 there F6 and then E5
and as he pointed out the bishop is now
biting on granite to borrow my favorite
expression and black is also threatening
a fork on e4 which is not all that easy
to
Parry without further positional uh
concessions if you play E4 the other
night could get around to F4 anyways
this is a nasty idea
in this situation is there like a knight
of thief where that could harass black
so Knight F to D4 hitting E6 I guess I
could go Bishop D5 but you're saying
white we'll go Knight C6 and get the
bishop pair Perhaps Perhaps yeah
I would have at least been slightly more
hesitant as Levant you can also go with
the other night but I'm worried there it
could be like E5 E4 potentially
yeah concretely I actually think Knight
bd4 E5 might even win materials straight
away guess what it's Knight F5 there but
black is still going for in that
position with some complications
right that would be crazy but I think
kikaru okay there's also a rook C7 too
so quite a few options to sort of uh
take advantage of that F6 move
maybe Hikaru thinking about which Knight
to put on D4
at least partially
and we're about to get some fireworks I
think yeah night after so yeah let's say
954 I've been thinking about this
position
and now okay Bishop D5 I guess if Knight
C6 you want to keep that really powerful
Bishop in the middle on D5 so I think
you'd go rookie eight
now what would you make of that
rookie eight
after an ic6 so Bishop D5 Knight C6
rookie eight yeah yep and then I take E7
you take back
I put the other Knight on D4
then you can go Knight E5 I mean I agree
that the bishop pair isn't exactly a
game changer in this particular position
the knights are very uh jumpy in in this
position with a lot of weak squares that
they can sink their teeth into
yeah and then besides Bishop D5 like if
you want to play the move E5 but I'm
worried about
even potentially 96 like there is of
course Knight C6 as well but it's 96 and
the Knights start hopping there's also
the crazy 95 sacking E6 but driving the
king out to DC I've been trying to make
sense of that for a while now he's
played it Knight takes D3
yeah okay first things I've been
expecting it and now
I mean Knight C4 almost works I don't
think it does but there's some like
mating ideas potentially the white king
stuck on C4 you're saying Bishop A6
Lavon plays the tame Rook to D7 he
basically just says hey I'm only a pawn
down and look at the state of White's
King
yeah he's gonna keep all the threats
alive I feel like if I'm in the car I
just want to get that King out of there
and I play too me too yeah
what is LeBron's follow-up to that move
is he gonna just snag the pawn on G2 and
restore no then Rook G1
right that would run into Rook G1 so
that's not an option what about [__]
face six
King E1
and right I guess
there is Knight C4 but it doesn't look
that menacing
okay Bishop A6 played good call King F3
I thought was out of the question but
maybe it's and nothing is out of the
question here
it might be in the question but I think
I just go back and ask you you know
would you like a draw a lightly looking
up at the opponent yeah kikara says no
and Knight C4
but yeah this is the critical position
what's he what's he up to now is he
gonna just play a slow move like King F7
Rook C8 oh Knight t495 ah oh that is a
nice idea you do not want to fall into
that acid card so probably Knight of
four instead is forced it is and it's
been played and now Lavon can keep
accumulating the pressure and he does
and somehow like no question that he's
got full comfort upon and probably and
then some there's like Knight A3 and
Rook C3 threats in the air a lot of
stuff going on that doesn't quite work
but you see what I'm saying I do I do
I'm picking up what you're putting down
and that Bishop on A6 sort of
controlling all those squares and cannot
be contested very important that white
doesn't have their own Bishop to contest
that nasty which could I mean could
really uh drum up some of these tactical
ideas which uh what you're thinking of
another big chance for Le Mans
especially given hikaru's clock time
A4 is a nice move though that's a calm
move in a difficult situation Hikaru
preparing to drive the bishop out of A6
with B5 and also creating a stronghold
on C6 to
reawaken a long dead conversation
and then maybe get his Knight around to
D4
yeah indeed it seems like a moment for
Lavon that he needs to figure out what
exactly can he do I mean it seems
promising there's certainly composition
which exists but it can really quickly
evaporate if he doesn't find the right
sequence
yeah it's not easy to find a move
somehow all of the key squares are
defended I like the look of Knight E5
here maybe setting up the threat of G5
yeah taking advantage that the pawn on
B4 is loose you could also do it in the
other order you could play G5 first
knock the Knight back and go 95 and what
I'm trying to exploit is the weakness of
the B4 Pawn that's the drawback of A4
but Lavon drops his Bishop back
preemptively
okay
threatening G5 and that G2 Pawn is
extremely targetable
it is maybe King F1
played yeah just
bullying on I'm yeah um one's close
oh man yeah time is dwindling
I still like the move g592 but I just
can't figure out a follow-up
Rook dc7 both players just kind of
staying composed making threats now
Bishop E1 comes to mind and The Rook on
C1 is protected twice so no discoveries
very important to note uh oh 10 seconds
for Lavon and Icarus kept the status quo
Jeffrey this is exactly what he wants
and he's going to play King G1 he's
going to make these slow kg moves and
wait I've been through this so many
times I know this feeling
and five things just gotta make news
Bishop D6 just start good move to Star
95 trade of Rooks maybe the other Rooks
will get traded
Rook C4 Rook C4 perhaps
Knight's gonna maybe re-maneuver to F5
92 is their Knight D3
Lavon keeps his control over the
position so far but two seconds taking
Rook C4 Gotta Move
Rook moves away The Bishop's attacking
the knights this reminds me of that
early game which Levon won or the
Bishops dominating the knights but Lavon
opening up an F4 Square for his Knight
and Knight D5 is a threat
oh man and if Sakura can somehow
position these Knights there is no entry
still he's gonna flag oh but oh now it's
starting to fall apart
Knight T8 Knight C6 is possible
now he's got this menacing Pawn majority
oh he blunders the pawn though
does win C5 at least rookie three Rook
H5 okay attacking two at the same time
Lavon staying afloat here oh first he's
done a marvelous job this is amazing
amazing play by levonne and now he the
worst is behind him he can well no he
can't play for a win yeah he needed to
somehow get an A5 there now this could
be somewhat unpleasant I've lost this to
Hikaru a million
three and it's a winning Pawn end game
he walked into a pin
oh my lands and it's over what was
Bishop C6 yeah he did such a good job
but it's so hard to maintain your
quality when you've been playing for two
seconds like the last 20 to 30 moves was
so difficult and if I may bring up that
game again again just to just as an
instant replay to show people where he
went wrong I mean it was as you said
marvelous defensive job but Jeffrey the
reason he played Bishop C6 I think is he
saw that after King A7 there was Rook H6
and Hikaru would have won this
um the way to draw was to go King E7 and
after Rook H6 apparently just giving up
the pawn gives you a pretty Untouchable
defensive setup but yeah holding this
with two seconds against Hikaru is still
be torturous yeah and the Knight is just
such a dangerous feast in time scrambles
it's an objectively better piece than
the bishop when you know the clocks get
down to two seconds a piece
yeah I did feel like the moment he lost
the a pawn and his car restored material
just not only having the Knight but you
have the F4 square and black spawns were
split in that end game so just a really
rough uh sort of grind down that Hikaru
put on there
and we have a Frankenstein Dracula
variation
um which I think is what this is called
I will I am unable to confirm that
hmm
but it looks like a good position for
LaVon in the early going if we rewind a
little bit
uh Queen H5 here
1960 he goes back to B3 now the actual
frankincense Draco I think goes Bishop
E7 icaro plays a weird move G6
now it doesn't blunder a rook because of
Queen E7 pinning the White Queen to the
king but Ron basically saying the end
game just sucks for black if he takes on
E5
oh yeah for sure Queen E5 D5 your knight
would be forced back but this end game
two I mean Knight for Bishop d8
yeah this is [__] troublesome
now maybe just grab on D4 and say now
I've got something to suffer for
eign
playing out of a cannonball here just
blitzing out his moves and Knight C7
Bishop D6 is going to come at some point
I think yeah I mean at minimum to gain
to regain your material but that Bishop
on C8 I can't stop looking at What a Sad
piece that is
yeah it's like it's like a tooth falls
out and you're you know
your tongue goes to that space just
can't you know a morbid fascination with
you know that piece which has no squares
so maybe Hikaru will have to try to go
B6 Bishop B7 at some point right now his
Knight is hanging and he's deciding
between 96 and Knight takes B3 which
defensive approach do you think he's
more likely to take I feel like when
you're lacking space you definitely want
to exchange pieces at least that's what
the principal says and all that car
would agree
and there we go everything's traded and
I don't think this is as bad as it looks
after B6 and Bishop B7 realistically
there's only one target which is the d71
and even if Hikaru loses that pawn
you know he will still have major
drawing chances here
you're right yeah it does look a lot
worse than it might be and black can
just trade Rooks here and go key and
fate exactly what he's doing and now
he's finally going to be able to develop
that Bishop
Levant definitely didn't squeeze all the
juice out of that position and maybe he
even played too fast in this case
perhaps yeah an over adjustment over the
last game when he played too slow that
does happen to me all the time
yeah you wearable the first free throw
of the new brick the second and I think
Hikaru is definitely holding this at
this point
but still very unpleasant I mean white
will put his Knight on F4
or E3 and start slowly just pressing the
car on both sides of the board
yeah I think these types of end games
are what people commonly associate with
super GM play just a position like this
the evaluation is 0.2
you're just kind of massaging and
finagling some sort of Advantage out of
this but Hikaru just sticking to his
course trading Rooks and saying how are
you going to make progress here Lavon I
think I can play C4 and get my king to
D4 or wait a second after C4 you might
have to move D5
which would get rid of that weakness on
D7 do you think you'll play T5 anyway I
guess now you have to reckon with King
E2 and F3
this voice
you would have be one yeah so I'm not
sure if you have to rush with D5 right
away I'd probably start out with a bit
like T6 which I think you need to play
in all cases
and he plays it and Lavon will he just
has he has to find a way to get his King
around to D4 so so C4
will come I think at some moment he
could also try F3 and then King D3 King
D4 but now the bishop has this diagonal
to chill on
yeah I've probably starting to
slowly agree with you I think it should
be able to hold this if he just stays
patient and waits I don't think white
really has a straightforward plan here
but I also agree with you that I to say
that this is a dead draw is
underestimating how how good these
players are and how good everybody at
the top is and and squeezing out wins
from you know just positions that look
ridiculously lifeless at times of course
Magnus is the originator
of this entire philosophy
maybe F3 and then some sort of like
Knight C2 Retreat to open up a pathway
for the white king
yeah maybe the problem is even if you do
get your knight in D4 I'll put my key on
E5 and say all right
exactly
just looking this is looking like it's
heading toward a peaceful resolution F3
played
so now choice of which diagonal to
retreat to I like actually I was going
to say I like the other one better I
would have retreated to C6 or B7
but this should I mean this should can't
you can't really call this a mistake
either
but at least here you can put one of
your pieces on the original square of an
opponent's piece which always feels like
a badass kind of move especially when
it's the same piece like a knight on the
Black Knight appearing on B1 oh yeah
yeah
always a good feeling
it's okay
right and I'm wondering as a card you
play B5 just because I I'm afraid if I
get kicked back and your king appears on
D4 then you might really start probing
and making some progress here then white
can continue pushing the seat Pawn the
Knight will have new prospects in the
center yeah and the fact that ikar is
taking as long as he is is a good
indicator that he is not comfortable
here
the work is not done
so after C4 oh yeah you can start with
F4 I guess basically even if black were
to push B5 that doesn't stop C4 y would
go B3
it's important to highlight the
defensive role currently played by the
Knight which is preventing The Black
Gang from infiltrating which would be
the nightmare scenario for white
and it will only move I think once
White's King is able to reach D4 it's
also of course supporting the C4 upon
break
yeah absolutely a magnificent job done
by that night I think here you go see
four you take on G5 and you play King D4
and then you think uh about your further
plan
agreed completely
Knight F3 instead but now King C4
I guess then I can always drop back to
D2 worst comes to worse it does reserve
that right but I don't think this is the
right approach I feel like he needs to
make C4 work and get his King uh onto D4
a great that just seems like the only
path forward you're not going to win
this game unless the white king
takes over the center and he goes Knight
to D4 but if the bishop drops back
Jeffrey like King C4 is always possible
where is he going from here is he gonna
go Knight B5
ah that might be his idea okay he just
wanted to get that Bishop like he felt
maybe it was like a thorn on C2 so first
kick that bishop and now he's gonna play
for the King on D4 but the big liability
now that he's created is that B3 Pawn
which is on a light Square it doesn't
have a path forward
so there's always going to be long-term
problems
with the black Bishop attacking that
Bond and if black wins that pawn then
Hikaru will have the possibility of
creating an outside passer it's a little
bit abstract but I feel like it's going
to be hard to win with that weight on
your back
no no no for sure you would have to be
wary of that outside passer idea at all
times he's gone King D2 here I think he
is trying to be aware of that Bishop C2
he wants to reposition this knight uh in
the in the coming moves yukaro's gonna
Chill on the B1 H7 diagonal with his
Bishop he just might go back and forth
between G6 and E4 and H7
and now I think it's time I still like
to move Knight F3 just because I mean
that D2 Square which you highlighted
earlier
protects B3 also can jump into E4 but
he's gonna put it onto another Square
he could consider spicing things up on
the king side with H4 the problem is
that Hikaru can simply ignore him
because G5 is protected by all of
Black's kingside pawns but Lavon could
try it anyway just uh
try to you know spice things up as much
as possible
yeah definitely ask your car what he
wants to do about that whoa okay now B5
does he want B4 here that's the big
question B4 and has he fully considered
A4
another dilemma for Nakamura Who's down
to 40 seconds didn't take him long he
plays A4 careful now be careful very
yeah this is a committed decision but if
white were to try to get after this bomb
with King B2 you would be hit by Bishop
D3
yeah or Bishop F7 same effect
Lavon very patiently maneuvering his
Knight and anytime he goes King T4 he
can't let this Pawn promote
yeah Knights struggle to play against
those Rook pawns so that is important
points very important point he goes
Knight D2 how many moves does the Knight
made this game it is getting its money's
worth he could bring it around to A3 but
it has no prospects once it reaches that
square but he allows C5 does he go whoa
whoa whoa whoa why did he allow that
that might have been a slight slip of
the mind because now I just has a past
be fun and after he before yeah does he
have a39 B1 A2
oh my God it gets super tactical because
the bishop defends that pawn
yeah I wasn't sure what to make of that
that I mean you could even lose if if
you didn't calculate precisely Knight
takes F6 and you can't take the C5 Pawn
because you drop the bishop and the beep
on promotes now it takes an H4 Maybe
oh we get another Pawn rolling he gets
D7 with check and the knight's gonna
move back to E5 with Tempo I think
levon's winning now yeah no King C6 no
this is totally winning
just F5 at five wins on the spot you're
not stopping the pawns what's he doing I
think this is still within the margins
yeah F5 and that's it wow I I feel like
Jeffrey even at the very end if Hikaru
had somehow moved his Bishop back maybe
it wasn't that easy but what an end game
by Lavon I mean big round of applause
for what he just managed to do
huge win there calling it the whole way
Jeffrey I was pretty dismissive but you
could sense that there was juice to be
squeezed there
yeah I mean it those kinds of end games
are always not easy because you simply
have to sit and wait and your opponents
can exhaust all the options they have on
the table and Lavon did just that he was
also Johnny in the spot when the car
allowed the uh beep on break
yeah yeah C5 that was that was the The
Turning Point the car should have kept
his King on D6 and
looks like there would be no way to make
progress but
in any case it's still a one point lead
for Nakamura and we have yet another
Queen's gamut accepted structure this
one with the queen still on the board
and an early A5 B5 which we had talked
about in the previous game
wow Rook C5 not most of the move I've
seen
yeah yeah he's provoking it to be
attacked for whatever reason does he
want some sort of Queen A8 Rook fc8
setup but that would run into Bishop A3
at least in the existing version but
yeah maybe that is what he had in mind
before
and now he's like wait a second why did
I put my Rook there
moves it back yeah Rook C7 is much more
standard and now I think he does want
the queen A8
and then I said give me that parking
spot
she does we discussed this in the
elastic or white game which is the fight
for the C6 Square so maybe you bring
around the other night night to a three
95 Knight C6 exactly
yes so Knight F3 is very likely here I
agree
that rhymes
and then can blackout Bishop E7 to D6 to
curtail the knight's path
right I think you probably have to
because like uh the only other move to
deal with that would be Knight of D7 but
after cd5 Bishop D5 Bishop C4 I think
white would be getting too many tempos
so yeah after mission D6 maybe I take on
D5 anyway
uh-huh so you open the C file I take
back with my Bishop I guess
and I still like this move Bishop C4
yeah a trade of Bishops is out of the
question just so people realize why and
let's pull up an analysis board real
fast instructive positional point you
always want to identify which pieces you
want to trade and which you want to
leave on the board and here a lot of
that has to do with square control why
it get gains control of this massive
outpost on C6 and Knight C6 comes with
great effect now incidentally uh in this
position black can of course drop the
bishop back to B7 but still then white
improves the positioning of his pieces
anyways Knight to F3 DC and Knight E5 so
the player is taking a different path
than Jeffrey this is this looks really
scary for black
oh it looks terrifying I mean imagine a
night coming on C6 that might be just
game over and white temporarily
sacrifices the pawn but the C4 it is
just not going anywhere so the car was
certainly not worried about that um mean
well what exactly can Levon do like
Queen D5 would be a double attack but
white would simply plan it out on C6 so
that amounts to nothing
great Point Queen A8 so with quite a bit
of delay he plays the move we thought he
might play earlier but again Knight C6
oh and this is starting to look real
dicey for black did he miss Knight E5
I think he did yeah it's so easy to
assume when you capture a piece your
opponent will recapture a 95 just
ignoring and now the Knight finds itself
on this beautiful Square
um Lavon might have to sack and exchange
at some point but there's just no
compensation
I feel like that this is a runaway train
at this point unless he he finds a way
to play Knight D5 to B4
and get this Knight off of C6 at all
costs but also Jeffrey to add insult to
injury you could imagine a scenario
where white takes on E7 and switches
over to the queen side with Queen G4
uncontested dark Squad Bishop could be
real dangerous with G7 Under Fire it
really could yeah but I think Lavon is
counting on your night before idea
because after Bishop takes E4 Knight
before at least a car would then have to
decide what to do concretely
yeah and maybe he's already thinking
about that because Rook takes C4 is not
out of the question to keep the bishop
uh available for Bishop F3
that could be case could be made for
that as well perhaps right
yeah so definitely taking his time here
if he plays accurately he's going to
have an overwhelming Advantage so a nice
Moment by hakar to spend uh important
important clock
and a skill that he possesses in the
extreme just knowing when to slow down
the sense of when the critical moment
has arised and a critical moment is is I
think best defined as a moment where the
value of making the correct decision
increases where there's really only one
move that let's say keeps the advantage
or keeps equality
and Hikaru senses it but you don't want
to take too long he's down to two and a
half minutes
right you don't I was trying to make
this line work Bishop takes C4 Knight B4
97 rookie seven Queen D6 going for like
some sharp complications with the double
attack on E7 and B6 but I mean black
would have to move Queen d8 there so far
from Clear
so Rook takes C4 is sakaru's choice
and Knight B4 is not is not technically
forced I mean you could throw in a move
like Bishop to F6
to try to you know fight off on the
other side
but I don't know I mean Hikaru will
still probably go Bishop F3 there
and I'm I'm just worried that this you
know one more misstep is gonna send
Black's position into a tailspin
for sure yeah black is on edge as it is
and it's a struggle to find moves like
Bishop six very natural I would agree
but after Bishop three don't know how to
continue so he plays F6 cool
Big Move
and okay so I guess he's saying after
Knight D3 I'm simply going to take on C6
twice and you can show me what you got
no that is a pawn
E6 is weak but it's not easy to attack I
feel like a car should search for
something tactical here but but what
exactly I was even thinking about some
crazy moves like Bishop G4
wait a second six I really like you
remove Bishop G4
let's pull up a board real fast Bishop
G4 this must be what he's calculating
and he's played it
and the idea is f takes E5 Bishop B6
96 none of this has happened yet he has
played Bishop G4 and levana's thinking
and what do you make of this position
Jeffrey the Knight is hanging the eval
bar is skeptical but White's just like
all over him after Bishop E5 all the
pieces would be streaming and you'd have
two pawns oh my goodness yeah and
there's 97 check I don't know what the
move is here okay let's let's settle in
and wait
for this position to be reached because
I think it will be well there is another
option after fb5 you could take on c52
right sacking The Exchange and then
coming around and taking D5 there it is
it's played whoa oh my goodness a
Desperado open the f file
this is getting chaotic it's out of
control what if you so if you take on
these six
basically Lavon is saying that he's he's
just gotten a pawn out of this
oh my goodness this position should come
with a complimentary aspirin I mean this
is this is crazy
head spinning position he takes E7 first
but now Jeffrey the pawn on E6 is
protected and I feel like Hikaru is
getting the shorter end of the stick
here whoa oh another crazy move windy
sounds six
hitting the room any counter attacks by
both players both of White's Rooks are
hanging the bishop is hanging G2 is
hanging it can be captured this is a
move that should be considered going for
checkmate
I mean there are a lot of things to be
considered right now
um I will say apparently the best move
is Queen E8 I was actually looking at
this yeah because if you simply uh
defend on e7e6 white doesn't have any
other threats like the problem still
exists both of your Rooks are hanging
not to mention the bishop G4 and the
pawn on G2 so we find this cool complex
and move we need such a cool move it
should be pointed out that if you take
the rook and then take the bishop and
you say I'm up a piece white recaptures
on E6 forking the king and the Knight so
this is the car's main idea he's put the
whole Square short
but this still looks good
to me at least it could lead to an end
game where white is an exchange down
with some compensation right it's a very
similar idea
um what sort of benefits does occur have
like if you take 2016 HD yep now you
take d8 and you take E3 and you move
your bishop and you say hey I've got the
two Bishops I've got a big Pawn on B5
and I've got the idea of Bishop C3 I
like hikaru's position from a practical
standpoint huh and there is this
annoying background problem so Rook D2
would be very ideal for Lavon but he's
awesome first
and maybe he overlooked that detail what
about Bishop D5 here
to go for something oh no you can't play
it because takes and Rook Cafe again
exactly so he makes love but now Bishop
C3
it should be four you could have a rep
no Bishop A5 he wants Rook to A8 to win
the pawn back on A4 great move by LeBron
yes and I think that works because even
if white gets in Rook of Fate you don't
have a clear follow-up
the king can escape through G6 even if
Bishop G8 happens or just keeping things
under control with Rook C1
I'm getting worried for Lavon here once
again
such a tricky position here for both
sides to navigate and notice how Hikaru
keeps all the infiltration scores
protected by the two Bishops all three
squares are under control 10 seconds on
lavon's clock yeah he doesn't want to
allow Rook trade super complex just
gotta start moving here King G6 it's
getting crazy against C4
H5 what's going on
the Bishops dancing around
A5 no I feel like it can be captured
yeah there's no more rookie 8 with the
bishop F3 no lavon's losing control of
this now B6 is going to happen oh man
now the punch is rumbling forward and
the Bishops are just monsters in this
position
E6 maybe there's still Bishop before
Hikaru playing it slowly maybe trying to
involve his King so does LeBron Rook H1
though oh
that's okay now just Rook H5 yeah
picks off The Rook you can't even get
the bishop in return and there's
Checkmate on H5 unreal all right
what a brutal sequence there by the car
that is just that I just have no words
for that
I have no words for that
what did we just see I mean he found all
of those moves instantly you also called
it you were there
but geez I mean so hard to keep up with
him down down to seconds
yeah and Lavon kind of still reeling
from that game they're taking their
sweet time to rematch this next game
will be the final one
of the segment and queen d8 I guess that
was the Practical culprit that end game
JX with the amount of weaknesses that
black had
was incredibly hard to defend and also
you're playing kikaru oh man I mean
chess is so cruel just one square away
if he had played Queen E8 he would have
been nearly winning but instead after
Queen Y8 that was so instructive how
Hikaru didn't allow The Rook trade down
exchange which was the key he played
Bishop C3 stopping infiltration on D2
followed by Bishop 2 starving
infiltration on D1 and after that it was
just so practically hard for black and
I'm just showing this on the board the
players uh just fixing some issues here
uh but this gives us an opportunity to
just quickly instant replay what
happened there I I think that people
take for granted Jeffrey is is moves
like Bishop E2 and moves like H4 how
many people would just take on A5 or
play B6 or do something drastic and make
a weakness not Hikaru he keeps the
tension so well until it's time to
pounce he's like Floyd Mayweather in the
ring he's defensive but then the moment
you make a weakness you expose yourself
he balances mercilessly
I mean so well put yeah it's just
insanely good at those kinds of
positions and exactly how you said just
waiting for the right moment to strike
okay so a big moment for Lavon he's got
white he's got to try to make something
out of this out of the white pieces here
and
ikaro resorting to a very solid Choice
Queen's Gambit declined
and an incredibly well studied variation
with Bishop F4
yeah for black you have a few options I
believe you can throw in a bishop before
check you can also play C5
um it's ah there he had a game against
fobby from a grand chess tour I remember
I I don't quite recall if it was [__]
before or C5 but in any case we are
going to see some sort of iqp I'm on the
board
so I never know Jeffrey if white should
take on C5 or allow the move C4 I feel
like it really depends on the position
okay there's our answer and will he
carve a place he for
yeah that's a big question like C4
Bishop C2
we are gonna see it and now uh E4 a very
typical Mass here counter-attacking in
the center so classic and you can't
really take because the Rook gets
dropped so now I've seen people Knight
f60 594 it comes to mind
you can also Play Bishop B7 but Lovato
Drive the pawn to E5 and that's always a
good thing for white
right I'm so convinced yeah I don't know
it's a hard position to evaluate really
like I'm also worried that the Knight 94
could become vulnerable although 92 is
interesting just sort of wanting to
trade and at some point maybe Levon
wants to advance F4 F5 he has to because
the ikaro's plan is so clear-cut B4 Rook
C8 C3
so Bishop to E6 here I think Levon will
drop his Bishop back and Hikaru could
also try to meet F4 with F5 you could
get an opposite and things could get
spicy and dicey on the king side I like
hikaru's position though and he doesn't
even play Bishop E6 he just goes
straight
for the throat on The Kinks on the queen
side
yeah I think he is gonna have your
long-term uh plan meeting F4 with F5
later on he says why should I develop
the bishop I also noticed yet with the
move A5 you have this idea to sometimes
play Rook A6 where the Rook sort of
controls the sixth ring a fantastic idea
we saw that in in the last a round of
the candidates and due to napomnishi
it's it's actually a pretty
widespread idea so good call there B3 oh
Big Move by Lavon allowing a protected
passer on the third rank but white gets
the battery going and provoke provokes a
weakness what do you make of that right
that would that would be a permanent
productive pass points either for the
rest of the game essentially and I think
Levon is banking on the fact that he's
going to keep as many pieces on the
board as he can because in an end game
that could be a significant issue but
with pieces maybe this one C2 can keep
it at Bay and it's interesting that
icaro has decided to keep the tension
but now white is actually threatening BC
and I think Lavon should maybe play BC
okay oh yeah
I feel like see there was D5 exactly and
this doesn't feel the most ideal for a
car although it's certainly still is
interesting
oh he's got the C file he's got the pawn
majority and I think he's gonna have a
rook established on C3 but after Queen
B5 ah Queen A8 with the idea of Rook B8
is nice
get off me and then the queen can
support the A4 Pawn push the car's
pieces are so well placed here
oh man that was actually a really
important detail which I believe Levon
missed
yep
because now
I mean I was going to say how do you
deal with with Rook B8 like you don't
want to put the Quran a for your queen
to Simply Be trapped but if you allow A4
then your Bishop becomes trapped
oh it really is because black dominates
the C file and Lavon has not gotten off
the ground at all on the king side I
mean he's got zero
things going for himself on the other
flank this actually might this this
might be borderline losing for white
I really don't see a good maybe I guess
you play Bishop a four no but then Rook
a three
I like Bishop D2 forced The Rook off at
least give yourself a little bit of
breathing room on the K on the queen
side but hold on after a beat where do
you intend on playing your queen E2
wait a minute there's is there
no A4 Bishop C3 a B I don't think it's
quite enough
but you could potentially just drop your
Rook back here
and you're saying that there's no good
way to he's played a four
but how does this work I just feel like
the long-term problems with the connect
that connected passers are gonna are
gonna haunt white oh my God you're right
I I completely misvalued this I thought
white would be able to just block the
pawns with his Bishop but I mean
you're completely tied down he is and
Luan Desperately Seeking activity but it
should Bishop A3 and it's only a matter
of time before Hikaru uses his heavy
pieces and the Bishops to pry to just
disrupt the blockade and once the pawns
get going white is toast
yeah I mean absolutely that comment is
spot on it really was like a positional
Rooks actress but you have
two pawns that are nearly promoted and I
mean you're lots of good options uh for
a car I like Bishop A3 and White's
obviously not going to react but that
added strain on White's position the
Queen's gonna come up to A5 and there's
just so many Avenues and angles that
white has to protect I I don't see this
happening for Lavon
and that bishvan E6 does such a good job
of stopping any sort of nonsense that
white would try to try to do
fantastic point it protects F7 there's
no Queen F3 LeBron desperately trying to
drum up some counter play but it's just
so slow
yeah Queen A5 does this just win on this
spot because you attack both both Rooks
well there's Rook C1
but it's like it feels like he Cars one
good move away from pushing White's
blockade I have this idea Bishop F5
Bishop C2 yeah but then you have to
watch for E6
it's gonna go for it anyway
okay
maybe H5 now
I think you have to try at H5 and meet
Bishop T2 with some Bishop A3 and E6 and
pray that there's something there
it almost feels like your car has
calculated this like years ago oh he
just takes it oh he's played E6 first
and now he plays H5
okay still some hope here if you get the
move H6 in yeah this is far from totally
being over
yukaro just keeps his foot on the gas
pedal but after H6 I think he just wants
Bishop f8 he wants to eliminate the pawn
oh so clinical that would be yeah you
just disrupt any sort of Queen E5 ideas
but Queen E3
keeps the pawn alive White's life hinges
on his ability to keep the spawn on the
board
and he's also attacking B3 might I add
aha
now wait a second Lavon looking a little
bit better here he I wouldn't say he's
back in business but Hikaru needs to
keep
his composure here
okay there is a move A1 which would win
the bishop I don't know if that's the
kind of trade I mean that you want
that's a lovely tactic though promote
Force the bishop back and then trap it
with the other Pawn
but yeah I mean the question would be do
you consider those the A and B pawns to
be worth more than that Bishop
yeah and Hikaru says I just want to keep
detention Rook e to C1 comes to mind
that threatens Rook C6 and maybe a sack
on E6
yeah I think that is
and Lavon plays it
okay so Hikaru preemptively moves the
bishop back to F5 it's been here before
and what if I go so Roxy six just move
the queen away I guess I guess Queen d8
and maybe Queen H4
that feels a little bit Airy after Queen
E5
uh when when do you play Queen E5
because you still have to keep an eye on
the H6 spawn
yeah that's a good question oh yeah I
forgot that that one that that actually
is debilitating the fact that you have
to keep the queen on E3 right you're
just totally tied down
so after yeah I do like Queen d8
threatening Queen H4 and white needs to
come up with something in the meantime
maybe Rook back to C3 go after the B
Pawn Queen needs such a Hikaru move he
just sort of uses both sides of the
board
so effectively see a move maybe just G3
I mean maybe you've got a stop Queen H4
he does it another way
and seconds for Nakamura yeah I mean
this is not exactly the easiest position
to play with load time
and the eval bar is so misleading I mean
minus four yes it's winning but so many
things to keep track of if you're Hikaru
repeat seven I'm getting concerned about
the back rank though he vacates it maybe
G4 G5 just to take the
stress off the queen oh excellent idea
ship C2 is nice
okay G5 I think but that doesn't lead
anywhere you don't have any infiltration
squares
right the bishop does such a good job
but a good move by levonnie just keeps
you know keeps the the web weaved around
Black's pieces
and is there rookie five
apparently there was yeah there was some
chances indicated by the evil bar but I
didn't see it oh now rookie close now
there's rookie seven and Rook B6 and if
you promote you just ignore you take it
you go King G2 and the combined threats
of the eighth rank check and the
infiltration to G7 give white enough
counter play but that's so hard to see
but he might find it because if not
there's really nothing else you can do
queen a is lining up a double attack you
attack on the rook and you're
threatening to promote do not go Bishop
A1 that's way too oh yeah The Rook also
hangs so you basically have to take on
E7
oh you you missed it but rookie where
there's white is winning now
still Rook B7 right oh and if Bishop D6
you drop F7 with me but Lavon playing
too slowly
I think he should still have this like I
mean Carl only 10 seconds to deal with
that Rook I mean just Rook B7 right he's
also good and queen C7 comes black has
made no progress on the queen side
six Queen takes H6 again
no but Queen wait a second
was a move and suddenly it's game on
Queen F6 ended the game on the spot
for Lavon now it's anybody's game again
as you said
and maybe a Perpetual check ing G3
he goes F3 instead I think there's gonna
be a Perpetual oh my God that's insane
a big missed opportunity there at the
end for Lavon and he's got to avoid
flagging well what if I oh yeah he only
has two seconds I just realized oh he's
playing for it though but he's watching
hot calls
checks
oh my God
it's winning how did he do that
wait a second it's not over yet King
he's 70. oh my God Levar might lose this
how many pawns is this Five Pawns for a
rook you don't see that Lavon gave away
his pawn and hikar was playing for a win
now after E3 he's gonna win oh this car
is going to win what are we witnessing
holy [__]
D3 probably E2 or
wait a second
oh oh
I still can't process this he's gonna
flag
oh yeah there's just no time but the
pawns we're promoting no freaking way
no way we just saw that
I mean I'm at illustrating that
that game was just a roller coaster of
emotions and all Lavon had to do I mean
forget everything else that happened
this is actually not easy he has to find
the crazy G5 and the point is that black
is in zugzvan black is Justin there are
no moves but Lavon he missed the check
on C5 because he thought black has to go
King E7 and now you take the bishop Carl
manages to win the pawn and keep the
bishop on the board ridiculous
ridiculous
man and we see Lavon I feel like his
expression says it all like he can't
believe it himself
and he came back from a losing position
in the opening Jeffrey it was an
incredible play he was so resilient but
against Hikaru
I mean it's just the guy just doesn't
die and he keeps his foot on the gas
pedal even when he's totally lost it's
five and a half two and a half
holy man really yeah I mean we could
have been easily seeing a different tune
had Lavon won the game put it within one
but now it is a three-point margin
um I feel like smarter chess might have
actually predicted this but yeah we'll
see if Lavon can can hit hit it hit him
back we will indeed it's the perfect
time for uh for a break as the players
transition to the three plus one segment
but uh we wanted to First remind you
that holiday Bots are back challenge
challenge Bots at any level from a 700
rated powder the Snowman to a 2100 rated
Mrs Klaus can you stop her rise to the
Grand Master title don't miss your
chance to beat all of the holiday Bots
before the year ends chess.com play
slash computer has it all or drop X Glam
holiday in the chat for the link well
ladies and gentlemen we are seeing a big
dose of crazy and a big dose of nasty
from Hikaru Nakamura will Lavon manage
to come back from the three-point
deficit as the three plus one segment
kicks off we will find out on the other
end of this short break
[Music]
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess but with a duck quack quack
how to play duck chest the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck click on a
square to place the dog
haha oh he put the deck to prevent moves
of opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the pawns King to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemate but still wait there is
still meat but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the fast time we have
winning duck chest
oh no no no no no no slip no no no no no
no I won
ah duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
a storm is brewing Dimitri on Jacob
Drake is a wizard within the Tempest the
best have come to test their skills and
brave the storm
oh we missed it oh
my goodness the wheels the wheels have
come out that could be the magic for
some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness Knight d8 whoa
oh my God what a tactic
this is insane oh look at Fabby
exhausting every last resource the
battles will be Electric
the moves will be fast it's game over
it's winning oh my God he's gonna make a
queen the stakes will be high he just
grabs his head he can't believe it he
just gave away the pawn the 2022 speed
Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
the many facial expressions of one
Hikaru Nakamura the pineapple in the
background the YouTube Awards on the
Shelf were all familiar with his
background and of course the orange
walls to top it all off yikaranakamura
leads the speed Chess Championship round
of eight matchup against lavonaroni and
five and a half two and a half
commentating alongside GM Jeffrey Zhang
Jeffrey Zhang as we look at Hikaru
nakamura's match-up card I mean
we've talked about every aspect of his
Blitz at strength you know what more
needs to be said
yeah not much honestly and those
insights right there I think they say a
lot that's simple but true I mean we saw
it from that last game accurate and fast
when I mean when you get low on time
against the crow he just finds every
nasty little trick there at the end to
try and exploit your time trouble and in
that position it looked like he was a
dead duck but he found a way and
I mean it's a really unfortunate end to
that five minute segment but now Lavon
needs to sort of lock in and try his
best to uh make this a match I Can't
Take My Eyes Off of the SEC score I mean
22 and two I talked about Floyd
Mayweather
uh this is Floyd Mayweather like from
Hikaru and indeed the score five and a
half two and a half after the five plus
one segment we will now have an hour of
three plus one
listen I mean these games have all been
very competitive I I can't say that
Lavon has gotten blown off the board in
any of the games but Jeffrey I mean the
amount of times that the game has come
down to five seconds for both players 10
seconds for both players we talk about
it again and again Hikaru is just
Unstoppable in those situations and the
last game was a case in point
yeah it's so so tough to drag him down I
mean just to get him into trouble to
begin with is not easy but then that
phase of forcing him to really give it
up just so tough I mean what more can
you say
yeah no absolutely crazy Lavon has a
comeback to mount here but he's got
plenty of time to do it and can he
manage the speed the three plus one
segment is the time that Hikaru has
traditionally pulled away from a lot of
these speed Chess Championship matches
um he defeated paravian by 12 points and
once hicaro gets into the Zone once he
starts winning I mean nobody not even
God himself can stop him
all right speed belts fastened Hikaru
has the white pieces in the first game
and a berry system essayed by Nakamura
he's played all sorts of offbeat D4
openings
yeah and I think also we should mention
that Lavon did open with G6 on move two
he had been playing QJ but being down
three points in the match I think he
wants to spice things up a little bit
with that king size fiancado
Indiana a sensible strategy
but Hikaru keeping it very solid uh this
is kind of a a chameleon opening that it
can be both tactical and positional
depending on where White Castles you can
play it with an early H4 I mean not
anymore or you can play it very in very
tame fashion by castle and kingside it
looks like he car is opting for the
latter approach
right it does seem that way I guess he
is gonna just make a short Castle here
and I have a very slow build up to this
one
indeed
and E4 E4 is on the board looks pretty
Pleasant for white at first glance
but there's also all sorts of ways to
harass White's Center
uh-huh yeah I'm not sure what to make
the net on C3 you typically want to
protect that D4 Pawn with a c2c3 so
slightly unusual placement of the white
Knights here early on
yeah you would kill for a Pawn on C3
then you would get a very typical Karo
Khan type structure as it stands black
has long-term pressure on D4
but ikar trying to reshuffle his Knights
prevent the Bishop from coming out
it's just a sort of a normal position so
far hard to make any hard and fast
conclusions
yeah the Nancy five oh Bishop drops back
all the way to see what I was not
expecting that
on developing
yeah I mean fish for far more natural
but he's gonna move that Bishop around
like a yo-yo but he's about to be hit
with Knight F5 and maybe bishop F4
Bishop B5 just keep on theme no but that
drops D4
uh a little bit too conventional I feel
it from occur and after Knight F5 I
guess he's gonna just allow
uh Lavon to take his Bishop here maybe
nothing better than C3
yeah and if I'm LeBron I'm not rushing
to take on E3 but he just rushed to take
on E3
and he's gonna Mount long-term pressure
on this very tender E3 Pawn H5 Bishop H6
good stuff for Lavon great play so far I
love that idea he's also got a potential
E5 lurking the further blast that Center
maybe now there it is
good call
and at this point you're starting to
think about you know tactics it's pretty
it's too early for anything
drastic here
so maybe a tame move like Queen E7 is
what the doctor ordered
yeah sure I also think at some point B6
because that Nano C5 does prevent me
from developing the bishop so I might
want to kick that Knight out but yeah it
does player Queen E7 move
I think V6 might have been more accurate
now Hikaru will probably move this
bishop away from the X-ray
and it does Bishop G4 maybe just
continue developing
yeah Miss G4 just connect Rooks with
Rook d8
looks like a very sound approach and at
some point there might be an 84 with 93
not yet because of that seven point but
something to keep an eye out for
and white shouldn't rush with E4 I think
a lot of people would be tempted by this
move but that yields the F4 Square it
loosens the D4 Pawn so Hikaru has to
tread a lot more carefully here as he
prepares to involve The Rook in the
defensive effort I like the way he's
handling the defensive task so far
indeed yeah I would agree with you I
think both sides are playing this pretty
naturally I feel like we'll see a rook
Ada then we'll follow with Rook ae1
and that's when the real battle will
start
but already look at the clock Levon down
40 seconds and you know he car is just
going to rinse and repeat you had a
complicated position milk is clocked
down and force Lavon to prove it in a
Time scramble
oh yeah I'm getting worried for him the
move I wanted to play was Bishop F6
I'll try and kick that Knight on G5 out
but white would swing over the other
Knight in that case I think with Knight
C4 so I wouldn't really be getting rid
of that Knight
yeah that night both nights are just
irritants here he goes the other way
which I like Bishop to H6 which doesn't
preclude strictly speaking the
possibility of Knight C4 but that move
no longer comes with Tempo so maybe it's
best bet for Hikaru is to just sacked
upon on G5 but but how is he gonna do
that exactly
right and more importantly with Bishop
H6 you reserve the option to play F6
it's very important because the Knight I
mean you wouldn't want to move it away
um opening up Black's Bishop
so sacked upon he does
technically not a sack because B7 will
hang in the end but I I don't know if
he's gonna he's funny to capture that
pawn
right you don't necessarily have to jump
the gun he takes an E4 it doesn't fix
right F6 takes him yeah this
just something about it
agree um I think Rook F6 solves black
White's problems okay yeah your knight
gets pushed away but that Rook is a
monster Queen F2
and you really can't attack the G5 Pawn
so White's gonna be able to hold on to
this clamp practically I almost think
the white is better there's also the
long-term idea of pushing C4 and
disrupting a pawn chain so maybe Knight
D2 at some point
exactly he's gonna at least try and
block the F5 Bishop F5
okay so an end game
and Hikaru carrying out the idea but you
don't want to go C4 prematurely and give
up the C file
right well that King is starting to walk
in
now you strike with C4 here
's it with B3
but now a four-stroke trade otherwise
black stroke would have infiltrated to
F2 and looks like Levon is the one with
his foot on the gas pedal here oh B4 is
committal now afterwards move
your line pass Bonds on both sides of
the board but now something yeah I'm I'm
wondering why not C5 he finally plays it
Lavon maybe should have taken on C4 but
that was very hard to evaluate now it's
a two result it's a three result game
I have a feeling that both sides are
going to be
kind of solid the after G3 H3 looks like
a fortress because black the black king
simply can't come around and Hikaru
could try some Shenanigans with his
Knights now BC again is possible and
then King E5
wait a minute oh he is initiating some
serious complications
oh but c692 oh he gets around to D4 he
blockates the pawn he defends B5 and
Levon can keep hunting with his King
though
still very tricky for both sides uh oh I
think it might be getting dicey for
Hikaru
breaking up the pawn chain but allowing
A4
yeah I mean once you eliminate the a
pawn White
shouldn't be at risk but yeah this okay
now both sides will be waiting maybe
Levon had a chance there but given the
fact that he's got three seconds
cannot blame him for playing this a
little bit more conservatively
yeah and here's Hikaru might milk as
much clock as he can
yes somewhat I mean one part of it is
milking another part I feel like he's
also thinking about the game in the back
of his head is what strong GMS tend to
do
but yeah it will repeat it now and
Hikaru definitely tends to do that a lot
you when when he gets into a bad
position over the board you sometimes
see him you know assiduously studying
his score sheet you know trying and
everybody does that right where exactly
did this get away from me but still I
think a positive result for Nakamura who
was in quite a bit of trouble out of the
opening there I don't know if he's going
to repeat that experiment in in the next
couple games
I agree with you he was on the ropes
playing against that Bishop parent in
the weak epon but in this game okay
Levon still going to stick with the
Bishop's opening uh I think Hikaru made
his slight adjustment because I recall
like a queen H5 Landing in that other
game so now something slightly different
in Knight takes E4 typical uh little
tactic here displayed by a car whoa whoa
whoa whoa but D5 this is traditionally
considered bad for white like you're
taught this when you're you know in your
mother's womb that you don't really want
to take back on F7
I think what Lavon is banking on is an
early D4 he's going to contest the
center but I'm still skeptical Jeffrey
it does feel like you've just given up a
free center with the bishop Perry like
okay you did induce King takes F7 but
after King J I'm very happy I've
finished my artificial castle and for
sure black is not the one uh fighting
for equality
yeah not exactly
you know
the best kind of opening play here for
Livonia he's fine Bishop B3
you're just going to see a bunch of
normal moves here but Hikaru is
definitely happy with the bishop Aaron
an open position
here I'm wondering do you take on C6 and
play this structure
or do you just you know develop with
rookie one and so on
yeah that's that's the million dollar
question I think I think you keep the
status quo I I think Lavon has shown a
propensity to doing that so far in this
match maybe rookie won Bishop B3 the
issue with Bishop B3 could be this
Knight maneuver to C4
mm-hmm and potentially the G4 as well
yeah I like this move
okay and again keeping the structure
there could be like a knight H5 jump in
the air
very much in play
B6 I wasn't expecting that I thought
he'd go C6
right this feels so slow like I
understand he wants to feed and keto the
bishop but the bishop would then be
removing uh control over some key
squares on the king side so a little bit
unsure
yeah Bishop B5 and it just feels like
black center is under a lot of pressure
now
and I still like this move Knight H5
because you would be preparing ideas
connected with Queen G3 and suddenly I
mean that Bishop you know Bishop C7
Bishop D6 Bishop B5 all sorts of ideas
come into play yes learn Pine yeah yeah
Queen G3 for sure
Queen G3 is uh
hard hard move to refuse and it's played
like the way Levon is massaging the
position in the first two games but can
he actually deliver can he there's a
very variable yeah I want to say there's
a very easy tactic to blend if you go
Queen D7 which makes sense uh connecting
the Rooks there would be this move
Bishop D6 first attacking the rook and
after Rook of seven I can take one of
six and rookie seven
fantastic point and that's why Hikaru
says I don't want anything to do with
the G file
but I mean of course Bishop D6 is still
in play as is a move like Rook to E6
just accumulating pressure on the king
side but is there anything concrete
no but this looks fantastic like if you
try and kick me with Bishop C8 I just go
Rook D6 there goes your D5 Pawn but
otherwise I mean I'm just doubling
so will Hikaru go actually Queen to
because Queen F5 Rook takes F6 Queen
takes H5 black is balancing
on the on the trapeze here but it looks
like he's getting away with it
yeah that would hang on by the skin of
their teeth
I have six Rook of six so you can take
the open E5 with rookie one I don't see
anything better
and again it almost feels like this
Advantage is starting to slip away from
Lavon unless you can get a bishop to E5
and attack G7
right like even Rook of the queen of six
rookie one there's just Queen F7
followed by rookie eight so I don't know
how he did it but ikoro seems to be
slowly unwinding this position
he makes it look easy I think Queen F7
Lavon is cooking up Bishop E5 and oh
there could also be 58 no no there could
be Bishop B8 trap I mean putting that
rook in prison try that on for size
that's quite the move and oops sorry
about that
Bishop E5 Play No Bishop B8 is an idea
that I've seen before he can play it now
how about them apples
and there's also 57 I just realized what
a tactic rookie seven at the end so
Hikaru keeps the pieces on the board but
oh that looks terrible oh that looks
like Bishop takes H6 I thought four
exactly yeah
he has to see those Queen Bishop H6
ended the game there
feels like he did yeah now he's got to
grind this obstacle Bishop engines which
at the very least even if a car loses he
you know forces Lavon to work and also
precious seconds took off of that mask
hook where if he had taken on H6 he
would have already won the game yeah no
Bishop HC had to see Bishop H6
opportunities like that you know against
the car are so fewer and far between
there's still chances here maybe rookie
seven
but the back rink is a little bit
concerning the past Depot offers
long-term counter plan Lavon has to
avoid flagging here which is always a
possibility
streets are very important to cut off
that g file if your car was playing for
a win isn't he Bishop A6 and there's a
mate threat don't take on A7
oh my God that's easy to blunder it and
Bishop A6 threatens made in one
well Lavon sees a made in one thread who
would have known
but here's the issue of Kings you
through this bishop
D3 hikara might win this oh my goodness
oh no why did he go back
oh no D2 and it's over Rook see what is
Unstoppable he's got no time yeah this
is no but this is
I mean that went South in a hurry
but it all stemmed from Bishop takes H6
which again you just have to see
but to win that end game in like five
moves
there's only one person on the planet
who could do that
yeah perhaps move on I mean if he wasn't
rattled before I feel like you just have
to be now but he'll try his best he'll
try his best to uh you know get back on
the saddle and hope to slowly regain his
form
it does feel like you know the four
point lead sounds overwhelming
whoa Bishop D6 that's a fancy little
move there very fancy Bishop F6 Queen F6
hits the rook in the corner that's why
what black doesn't lose the piece
but it feels like you know these games
really could go either way so if if
LeBron cleans up his tactics just a
little bit
he definitely has his share of chances
and I think he will continue to have
chances
right and we see a wide variety of inner
mezzles shown there I was wondering
after Bishop B2 was there another
Intermezzo that
white could have tried with [__] takes
E7 but at any rate we are stuck with
this very modest looking position here
pretty solid stuff by both
yeah Hikaru just going solid mode he
wants D4 Knight D2 very aggressively
equal position here just like as equal
as it gets
indeed we'll see if Lavon wants to mix
things up maybe an a6b5 don't really
know what that accomplishes but at least
you take some space on the queen side
maybe later and E5 and figure out what
to do from there
yeah if if I had to choose a sign here
I'd probably take black
um it just seems like he's got more
exciting prospects in the center as he
sticks the Knight on e4 and follows it
up with that five very typical
across many different openings
yeah it is a strange looking little
Stonewall idea but he does provoke the
move F3 which I'm not sure that really
benefits him but this is sort of just
poking and prodding making Making Moves
In the chess game your car nibbling
around the edges with A4
and the one striking in the center with
E5
now this move does cause the D5 Pawn to
be loose which might be a factor long
term
some sort of night before could come at
An Inconvenient moment and you
definitely don't want to play E4
Soviet Soviet GM
oh
Hikaru heading for B5
yeah he's got permanent access that B5
square and an eventual Rook B1 and B4
will follow so I think he's slowly
starting to work Levon in this type of
position he's also up basically a minute
which I haven't even noticed Lavon
spending more time
but apparently he has so
it doesn't feel like he's thinking but
yeah I mean just a one minute Advantage
I've known before one move and P4 is
going to be nasty when it appears I this
is where 0.00 is so misleading because
the trend of the game is favoring Hikaru
here he's the one who's clearly calling
the shots but things could go south for
white on the king side if he's not
careful like you know there's there's
stuff going on for Lavon as well
yeah but I just love the patience here
H3 kh2 and now B4 comes with a tempo at
some point lavon's Gonna Get Low on time
again we've seen the story before and it
feels like it's not gonna end well and
Hikaru is on a roll I mean he's over two
minutes on the clock he's playing with
tremendous confidence at this point
and he was shaky a little bit at the
start but once you give him a couple of
wins
you know it's that runaway train effect
and he's better in the end game
Lavon trying to create activity in the
center but the pawn can be defended
and once you defend the point I think
you followed it up with a move like
Knight A3 attacking both the C4 and B7
Pawns
1993 even here is possible and it's
played excellent call
right just getting rid of that c Pawn
and if you have to go D5 then of course
E5 becomes very tender
Rook before it's possible nice little
attack here by Lavon nice before met
with Knight D3 which is why I think Rook
B4 is a very good suggestion
and that's a misdirection you would
think Knight C4 Knight A4 but then the
Rook has the B4 Square Knight D3 keeps
that square controlled
maybe yeah Rook B6 okay so Knight takes
A4 he wants to bring it back to B4
right he's always
holding on to his cards 94 I think
simply move like Rook D1 because you
have so many ideas here Knight B5 also
you could double I just realized you
could double on the B file because the
moment B7 Falls then the a pawn promotes
maybe live on this is very gimmicky but
I'm looking at some idea with H4 try to
open up the E file on my G3 setting up
some mating threats
I mean you might have to try at some
point I think you do because your your
queen side is a lost cause at this point
yeah choosing between one of many
options
you know like
I feel like rookie wants the move you
want to play if you can just Rook B1
rookie seven yeah
okay Rook D1 defending the pawn and
maybe now is the time to play H4
I would think so
um yeah
navigating the a Pawns
G5
yeah Lavon trying to
muster up some counter play but it just
seems way too abstract the king is so
safe on H2
Rook B7 though important move stopping
A5 at least for the time being
check don't go to H4
foreign
's still in it and his pieces are very
active so all of a sudden
right that Rook is tied down but now
says 92. take that
well brilliant he should or should there
is Rook D1 though right Rook D1 94.96
Rook D7 oh that was
193. hey Carl going all in on the a pawn
perhaps but again levant's clock is down
to 10 seconds and it almost doesn't
matter what the evaluation is whoops
sorry Knight back to E4
yeah A5 Knight C3 is sharp so he takes
on C4 Rook C6 and C4 comes to mind
the Knight is very very well positioned
on e4 but again even if this is
objectively equal the time is gonna
really dictate what happens here it's
also annoying that the Knight dominates
The Rook Rook A7 would be such a nice
one so Lavon trying to shift it over to
A6 but some other Amazing Ideas I can
just take on H5 or maybe Rook A7 I feel
like that's a Hikaru s move no he does
take on H5 good call
and oh and you can't go to E6 because of
the phone he's got this and in this
ensuing night end game with the A and H
pawns it should be too much no it's
totally winning and LeBron's also
flagging
A5 it's over
I mean
it's just a
I mean it's just a machine he comes at
you in waves
yeah and it's really you can't emphasize
enough how much like the objective eval
at some point does not matter equal plus
one minus one
he just put so much pressure on you that
you might survive as you said the first
wave the second wave but at some point
you're going to collapse
yeah and we've seen that featured
already numerous times in this match
I guess I mean I want to tell favon like
if I'm in his corner just play as fast
as you can trust your instance but it's
not that easy like the moment you start
doing that you fall apart on the board
so it really I mean just facing a
monster such as a car was just not an
enviable task
yeah and and I think we're we're
starting to see that it is in fact the
three plus one portion in which Hikaru
so often pulls away I think some people
assume that he's just trying to make it
to the bullet but I actually think this
time control is where Hikaru is scariest
not even the bullet I think in the
bullet you know you can compete Hikaru
doesn't play quite as much bullet
anymore
I mean obviously still a beast but three
plus one is where you know where the
party's at for for Nakamura
yeah for sure I mean I do remember
oh yeah I mean you think about it Carl
and his bullet play but we know that
Lavon you know he can he can fight there
himself even in their last match I
recall back in 2018 I think you won the
bullet portion
but right now it's just all about
getting out of this book section try to
finish with some good wins and try and
keep your distance yeah I think we
should remind the the audience that
you know Lavon did win the bullet
segment against andrekin and he was down
by three going into it so we've also
seen nihal sarin lose a three-point lead
to Anish giri
um so crazy things have happened in the
bullet it just feels like if you're
going in with a six point deficit
against Hikaru
he's kind of immune to You Know The
Comebacks that we've seen uh in in this
season's SCC
and I do like lavon's position here it's
a symbolic Advantage it's got better
control of the center playing against
two Bishops but those Bishops aren't
exactly shining uh as white I think just
keep the pressure on you know Play Good
Moves useful moves Rook D1 H3 maybe you
bring a knight on C5 but just keep keep
it flowing
keep it flowing and level one does keep
it flowing by attacking A7
the queen is kind of nicely placed it's
out of the way of the other pieces
and it's directing traffic from from a
distance as it should
okay yeah
at some point I do oh E4 I was wondering
is this premature or not because after
Bishop G4
let's Bishop G6 but sometimes you have
this uh slight concern of overextending
I think Bishop G4 there might have been
E5
or the Desperado ah Bishop G5 Knight G5
nice tactic yes
shikaru just kind of contorting himself
that the problem again is that black
Black's Target so Lavon striking while
the iron aside while black is still
passive I love it well hang on a second
though what if I take with the c pawn
and E5 now he goes the other way
and Bishop E7 I think he wants C5
oh yeah because if he's able to put that
Knight on D6 he could actually turn the
tables completely and he could get this
benoni style counter play with B5 and C4
so maybe D6 just give the pawn up but
keep the files open
uh I'm trying to make him lose like H5
work but it's
it might be a bit too speculative
I feel like he's losing his grip on the
position like big time because he's just
not creating threats his pieces look
imposing but just B5 C4 and black is
so well positioned in the center that
Knight on C8 is an integral defensive
piece
truly yeah and just gotta find an idea
here and I just don't see it like 23
would be the move I want to play but you
just run straight into rookie eight
and he's gonna start slipping on the
clock very shortly
Queen to C3 setting up 95.
and the car is like nope
Bishop page five comes to mind oh Bishop
H5 is a great move takes it at least
here I mean why well hold on to this
powerful knight on D5 maybe did some
tackle ideas could occur with Rook C5
great call Rook C5 is a blundery car he
has to see that
and he does he does this is a big moment
I think you now hakuru at least is on
his heels you have to take advantage no
this is a must win like let's be
straightforward this is a must win and
Lavon has just gotten a big chance
okay Rook d8's calm moved by Nakamura he
might try to bring his Knight out and
smoke this pesky night out of D5
you don't necessarily have to move the
Rook although he does I was gonna
suggest me like Queen C2 keeping the
Tactical ideas alive Rook C3 now 96
okay
white actually might not be better here
no probably not
I feel like yeah somehow that last move
sort of ran out of steam and after the
knights get swapped there's just no is
there oh there's no Bishop H2 okay
yeah The Rook hangs in the end and Lavon
making space for his Rook to move into
D3 still some residual pressure here for
white and Hikaru low on the clock that
number seems to matter but
let's see if Lavon can manage to create
some chances here
it is tricky it's not easy to sidestep
this pin I guess you can see Queen C7 oh
Queen E7 there was Rook takes D6 exactly
yes you had to watch out
okay Bishop C5 and queen takes G3 ideas
but you couldn't play it immediately
just this solid move it should be seven
and the only way for white I think to
create chances to pressure that F7 but
one weakness and now I mean with
arriving on F6 there's just nothing you
can use this ideal setup and and if
anything Levon has to be
pretty uh pretty solid here to avoid
giving black unnecessary activity
and now isn't there a take in Queen C4
that's exactly what I'm talking about
rookie eight and now hikara wouldn't
wouldn't accept a draw anymore he's
better I mean oh and they're just like
they're yeah and their G5 ideas too
which exists I was thinking that too
very and now it's a big threat I think
oh man well Queen C4 there might be
rookie eight
well Hikaru repeat moves simply and say
hey I'm up five points I don't need this
I mean you couldn't blame him at all but
he's gonna fight on it
and he just he's also milking the clock
he's got basically no risk at this point
well queen bee threw in Rook B7 I I
honestly I should have taken the draw on
his shoes there I guess he's also weak
in the G5 Scourge is unnecessary now
lavon's starting to dominate I jinxed
him and he takes H5 oh man
a big turn around here and another
golden opportunity for aronian
take on A6
oh my gosh
Rook B3 nice inside oh but he gives a
rookie he blunders A4 and love and I
think this is very defensible now for
Hikaru
yeah that's me
very stunning decision to take with the
Rook there they're gonna abort this one
I'm pretty sure we're at the halfway
point
or maybe are we though
I guess they're gonna get enough
yeah
folks but what a turnaround there Lavon
big Kudos he just kept his foot on the
gas pedal even when things were going
south for him
well I should say that Hikaru did refuse
to draw for there so perhaps a little
bit overzealous but still a four-point
lead
um but yeah car might be looked might
look to tighten things up now for sure I
mean you want to keep it you want to
keep Levant arm's length here if your
car you don't want to lose another one
because we've seen three-point leads
erased all SCC long and Lavon I mean
he's obviously playing for a win here a
Sicilian
and Hikaru making a very fashionable
Choice Queen takes D4 I know you've
played this a lot Jeffrey I've played it
as well it's a dangerous line
yeah you often Castle along here double
the F pawns and Lavon doing a kind of
funny thing here putting that Bishop on
E5 but it could find itself in some
trouble funny or bad
maybe both
maybe both yeah and go like E6 but then
93 and Knight C4 you soften up the D6
Pawn in that case yeah that's positional
E6 I was maybe thinking even about F4
anyway before anyway wow but I like your
approach as well and now Hikaru
basically just has a free hand
in the center
yeah you still have ideas with G3 F4 and
trapping that poor guy on E5
the poor guy indeed
ugh
Queen B6 Knight C4 I'm wondering I might
get desperate here with Queen B6 Knights
for Queen F2 at least eliminate the F
Pawn I don't know if I could get away
with it but he does think better goes
Rook C8 yes he still has Queen D6 in
mind
yep I think it's coming coming next if
it's allowed controlling C4 is live on
to prevent Knight C4
which Hikaru could play here if he wants
to if he wants to beat Black to the
punch
but it's miserable for black
whoa
okay F1 okay gee I wonder what his idea
is well he just wants to keep ft yeah
I guess Queen B6 now he's got Knight B3
and F2
very importantly is protected in this
scenario
yeah actually you know the the scariest
ideas are the ones where you know
exactly what your opponent wants to do
and you're basically powerless to stop
him
yeah wow this is so
subtle but I don't see a great way like
maybe
again I mean E6 between D3 you solve
nothing
maybe like a Bishop Ford move
yeah and already Queen takes B7 is
actually in the conversation if you
think about a knight appearing on B3
you know blacks play on The Queen side
isn't isn't guaranteed so you've got so
many enemies at your door if you're
Lavon
and syncing once again in deep thought
you're under a minute it's got to come
up with something
let's see seven okay C3 comes to mind
but maybe that's a little bit weakening
yeah Queen D3 I guess is a more
methodical way
still F4 is a big threat
okay Lavon doing a good job of
untangling here
yeah maybe after night before you claim
it like Queen c4r for the end game he
does
okay
huh Bishop H6
maybe black should have traded I I
really don't know who that favors
all right I guess right now I think at
some point you will see the move H4
though undermining the G pawn and black
could get something going on the king
side
your car is trying to get his Knight
going but Lavon restricts him in these
six this is as good as it's looked for
black in really since the opening
I agree
it's gonna try I don't know if he wants
double on the FIFA or is this idea to
lift The Rook through the fifth ring
he goes Rook C1
maybe Levon could have considered
capturing and playing H4 but another
Pawn structure transformation this one
Jeffrey I think is in Black's favor
because now the D3 Pawn black can kind
of sit on that weakness
or not
wow he's gonna just play with C4 B5 very
direct approach on the queen side
I like this transferring the bishop
is the car we're gonna try to push or is
that just yield more squares for the
bishop probably you can't open that
diagonal any further
wait but now A4 here
oh that is a that is just a a disaster
grabs his head
oh can this might be coffee and wait but
why B4 ends the game
that was just too much I wonder if it
was a slip based on the reaction or just
an oversight but yeah that's tough I
think that was just tilt I think King C6
would have actually kept him in the game
right he wasn't losing by any stretch
yeah yeah there was no need to just give
this game away like that
holy smokes
man right after picking up a win himself
that's going to be a tough pill to
swallow heading into the break
total momentum destroying game because
if he didn't go A5 black was the one
holding all the cards there that was a
winnable game for Lavon and we would
have been talking about a three-point
match
nine to four Jeffrey I mean this is
Total Domination
yeah and this it is safe to say this
game will be aborted yeah
wow
well it's nine to four folks the score
should update momentarily
um what do we say just a classic Hikaru
match he's totally in control here
Jeffrey and Lavon needs just like a
crazy 180.
he really does just some
some you know
I don't even know what to suggest but
like any place some kind of Hikaru like
opening just to throw him off early on I
mean it's really time to find some
desperate ideas
but yeah I mean just
borrow is relentless
yeah he is but lavon's got a lot of time
he's got 25 minutes to work with and he
needs to start now but first the players
are going to take a breather and so will
we stay with us we've got more action
coming up here at the speed Chess
Championship 2022 yakar Nakamura versus
Lavon aronian continues after this short
break
foreign
[Music]
18 seconds for a black so not too much
time there either Rook C7 a7's falling
uh it is E4 he pushes the pawn this is
getting a little messy takes a knight F1
3 King E4 91
move you know oh my gosh 0.9 seconds
when that move was played
it takes it right yeah
but there was Checkmate in one for black
after Knight takes G3
oh my God that was and instead he played
here
oh my God A7 wins for white oh my gosh
foreign
[Music]
's background is a brick wall and he is
facing a brick wall in Hikaru Nakamura
here at the 2022 speed Chess
Championship GM Daniel nerdinski GM
Jeffrey Zhang bringing you commentary of
this super exciting match
Jeffrey I mean as we look at Levon
aronian's player card
you know his record is six and six it's
been up and down he needs you know a a
just the craziest Miracle of all time
really does and it's so difficult to
even suggest
because I mean Hikaru he seems to have
an answer for everything it's like
whatever you do
he's always got something up his sleeve
and
the SEC uh back in 2018 I felt went
along a very similar storyline with the
car just maintaining control throughout
the match I believe he won the five
minute and three unit portions there as
well
so yeah I mean it's a really tough uh
road ahead Hikaru just seems relaxed
he's so good at making these Minor
Adjustments to his play to avoid the
opponent getting any momentum I think
LeBron's best bet is to try to keep this
manageable going into the bullet I I
really think that you know a a
five-point comeback in these next 23
minutes is unlikely if he can get this
down to three or four maybe a repeat of
what he did against on draken is in the
cards we'll see okay he's got the white
pieces here and another Bishop's opening
on the board with an early c65 uh
carried out here by Nakamura
yes slightly different than what we saw
in an earlier game I think Levon played
Knight G2 there hey Carl did have the
option of taking on C3 playing D5 but
this is a more moderate approach with C6
you keep the structure intact keep your
Bishop there and at some point I guess
we'll start with castles or not
uh D5 that playable I guess so but yeah
in any case
pretty solid start for both
a lot of newer players are tempted by a
move like D4 in these positions but
opening up the bishop uh and creating
you know ossifying the center isn't
always the best approach for black so
you often see uh black trying to keep
the tension in the center but right now
he's got a defend E5 and you can do it
with Rook E8 you can play Bishop G4 of
course Bishop C3 and de is
uh also available at certain moments but
not here
right I don't necessarily want to give
the bishop pair just yet those are
Bishop G4 which was among your
suggestions after H3 I guess I gives up
this one and now D4 I guess he's saying
here we exchanged the other Bishops we
play this sort of different structure uh
it's an interesting one
yeah he does play D4 but obviously here
it's associated with a very concrete
idea
and white cannot Castle so Bishop takes
before Knight D2
deserves attention but ultimately hikar
is going to try to hunt for that Bishop
yeah we might see that in the coming
moves I do like just dropping back the
queen here with Queen E2 at some point
if I can eventually get in the move
that's to F4 I'm going to be very happy
but it was a different way here with C3
I quite like levon's position here
Bishop air a lot of mobility in the
center
but let's see if you can play
in uh you know in in good time
as he completes his development with
castles and puts his Rook on
uh the sort of traditional Square to
prepare D4 yeah I like at least that
he's playing fast let's move Rook D1 it
can never be bad and these are the kinds
of things that I want to see from Lavon
because I mean when he's getting in that
sort of immense time turbo even when he
has good positions he might not have the
time to convert so I like that he's
playing quicker now and another one if
you cover as many strengths that's
perhaps not discussed that often is his
ability
to avoid further mistakes in a like
let's say
0.3.4 type of position white is slightly
better it's unpleasant and Hikaru he
sometimes bends but he almost never
breaks he'll give you a slight Advantage
from time to time but then he will just
rattle off five seven perfect moves and
before you know it you're on the
defensive
oh man yeah that's happened to me myself
and here we go numerous occasions he's
doing it again before is coming and he's
going to carve out this massive Square
for his Knight
oh that is a huge idea can I at least
respond with Knight A3 maybe to meet B4
with Knight C4 you can and I think you
might have to
but I can still go B4 and queen C7
oh and if CB4 Knight D4 the bishop on C2
would be hanging
but I think I think he has to go for
that anyway because if you allow B4 with
your knight still sitting on B1
then how is the Knight even getting out
like you never want to take CB
well he's not getting his night out he
yeah
okay this is his idea he's keeping the
tension trying to trade on his own terms
but Hikaru threatening B3 that's easy to
miss we missed Donald Trump division he
missed it oh my God no and lavon's gonna
resign this one oh and in the wheels the
wheels have come off completely in these
last two games
they have oh I drinks them
[Laughter]
he had to go Bishop B3 there
stopping that idea but yeah I mean it's
it's just it's all gone sideways and the
reason that was easy to miss is because
Rook B8 right you think of that as a
defensive move oh Hikaru is defending
the B4 Pawn you forget that the B4 Pawn
can actually move and it doesn't have to
take on C3
and it's a six point lead for Nakamura
the largest of the match and he's not
stopping here he's not taking his foot
off the gas but I'll by any means
yeah D4 spring in the center I think
we'll see a D5 he is feeling all the
momentum right now playing quickly
playing loose playing freely
Levon needs to stem the bleeding in this
game
now the thing with the hanging pawns
though is maybe after Queen D7 you I
mean that's of course oh there is an id4
option sorry to cut you off
I don't know rightly so
so nice before
F6 Bishop F6 Bishop B5 Knight G6
the line goes on there it could win like
five okay so let's show this on the end
well actually no let's wait for his move
because we actually might very well get
that line
yep we will yeah white has to go for it
otherwise they're down upon you and now
do you go Bishop B2 or queen A5 is the
question because
when you defend both at the same time
wow no so then you take first and then
you go Queen A5 but then Queen B2 no
Queen B2 I think you have to go Bishop
B2 here for black oh
no but then Knight C4 no no Knight C4
there but then I take the rook and you
take D6 this is unbelievable I mean
there's no Hikaru calculated all this no
but sometimes yeah in that resulting
position black could have won another
Pawn LeBron going for the sort of
positional approach which I love I think
this is the way to do it exploiting the
awkwardness of White's minor pieces
aha
yeah I mean he does get permanent
control over the only open file that has
to count for something
high level positional decision making by
aronian Queen C3 could be super
unpleasant I mean the pieces are Mighty
discombobulated in the end game
very yeah and I think akaro has to drop
back here with the bishop by uh on B5
oh my lands
it moves like Rick C3 is a huge threat
after Bishop B2 yeah I guess just Queen
C3 anyway and that end game is very
unpleasant
yukara making kind of a slow roll sort
of move maybe trying to get a knight
around to C4 oh this is his idea
but now Rook C5 I mean at the very least
yeah I win that d-pawn yeah and maybe
you don't even take it maybe yeah I
don't ac-8 exactly there's no real need
to rush although
I mean if why can't it should be three
ah A5 there's no time for Knight C2
the pieces are just getting put through
the meat grinder on the queen side
but don't take D5 blundering Bishop F3
so tricky I would just go Rook C8 or
maybe even B8 to supervise the progress
of the pun
no I just said something and he did it
again
oh but although it doesn't take D2 and
take A2 okay this time it's not a
blunder
oh wow I need to have three puns and
that's just one B4 yeah okay what a
lovely idea you give up the piece you
walk into the Trap but he saw one step
ahead so Hikaru actually keeps his minor
pieces alive but he should be losing
here yeah that was I mean very
impressive moment there from Lavon I
mean everyone would normally stop at
their calculations once you see Bishop
F3 extend it and see that you're getting
not only three pawns but you're a
domination over the position was really
nice
very instructive you always have to keep
those keep calculating those lines
or B4
right you don't I mean you can just make
a past Pawn but this should be good I
mean just take on D2 cash in right
cash in and then win that eight bond
with Knight C4 in the end don't
overthink it whatever you do don't let
this get into a Time scramble Knight C4
that's the only way things can possibly
go wrong here
okay two also does the job
yeah because hecaro has to waste a Tempo
creating lufts which he's gonna do
yeah okay wait a second Bishop D5
well would run into Rook D3 I think it's
I think it's just Rook D3 here you keep
everything under control Bishop E2 and
Bishop takes B5
ah right now
defends The Rook simultaneously and H6
the very last trap so this should be
good A3 and B4
and looks like a very convincing win
exactly what the doctor ordered for
Lavon
the car is going to milk a little bit
more time off the clock here and it's
literally never over with him he's gonna
go Bishop H5
ah but he can't go Bishop F7 there
because of Rook to G4 check unpinning
the Rook with temple oh that is a nice
subtlety that's actually how the game
might end it might end like that oh but
no it corresponds it but yeah
I don't go A3 Bishop F7 Knight F7 and A2
oh and the pawns decide nice finish
where has this been Jeffrey throughout
the match where has this calculation
this level of sharpness been in the
three minute portion I don't know but I
guess I mean as they say better late
than never we'll see if you can follow
this up with another good performance
with white
is not gonna milk a minute and a half
off no but why Queen G1 like that
obviously you're up the house but
you want to end this a little bit more
convincingly well it's made in one so is
sicaro gonna sit this minute out is it
made in one though like E4
But to answer your question
yeah the answer is yes the answer is yes
he's gonna sit out this minute
and squeeze and he sees it he took him a
while to realize that there's no mate I
think that's what he was thinking about
and Lavon is now thinking I mean this is
precious seconds he's wasting
still at four it's not me it's just not
me
oh you think this is like no F4 oh my
God F4 Queen E6 everything yeah okay
okay but not Queen takes out four
because of King D5 it's like Dina
yesterday missing that mate in one with
Knight takes F2 you know it's made in
these positions
okay
this is fair game you know from uh from
a match perspective if you want to
maximize
your chances of winning this is what you
do right not necessarily what the fans
want
but at the end of the day You're
Expecting The Players to do what they
want what they need to do to win right
and psychologically it makes a lot of
sense to from the standpoint like you
want to take the wind out of the land
sales uh in a way in a sense like you
just maybe played his best game of the
match this is where you slow him down
maybe annoy him by
I mean spending all the seconds on your
clock
yeah and I I don't agree necessarily
with people who say that this is
inherently disrespectful or it's dirty
like again a match has its own strategy
and has its own techniques and not all
of them are going to be pretty and not
all of them are going to be entertaining
for the for the audience but it's part
of the game right and I I don't think
all players would have done that in the
SEC I think Hikaru doesn't need to do it
but I also don't think it should be
necessarily held against him
yeah certainly sending the debate now
Lavon getting very greedy here oh I
thought I was going to take on E5 but
that would be a bit too much it was
Knight of three so there is a double
attack though Knight G5 is the
significant one
yep and D5 cuts off the bishop what a
crazy opening
is this prep
probably not probably not probably this
is just Lavon from trying to play
quickly right yeah I mean you never know
when it comes to these top guys but I
like that Levon is trying to confuse the
card right he's not playing some sort of
mainstream Berlin line that car would
know very well this is uh maybe the best
attempt to get back into this match
it uh great and listen again we're
talking about a five point lead here
this isn't a 10 point lead what Lavon
needs desperately is a two or three game
winning streak and I think his goal
should be to get this down to three
points if he can get this down to a
three-point deficit he's been there
before and icaro hasn't always been
convincing in the bullet segment of the
SEC paravian scored some victories
I think you know this there's still a
chance here that's right and I think
there's a chance we see the move Knight
G5 with the idea h696 F7
I was calculating the complexities there
let's go for the more mild approaches
putting the knight in the center
yes
so what is sicaro going to do CD Queen
takes D5
you could trade and go Rook d8 all right
this is giving me a headache I'm just
gonna let Hikaru figure this out
yeah I think he will go for cd5
um there's also I guess the pawn is
pinned so you don't necessarily have to
resolve the tension right away maybe in
Knight C5 or a knight C7 is uh is a
possibility as well
G Gary 6 trying to kick the Queen off of
the fifth ring so that you can recapture
the pawn now Queen E5 here looks like
it's out of the question but maybe it
isn't
uh that would allow rookie with a Tempo
so not the most ideal Square I wouldn't
think it is it is out of the question
okay
so C takes D5 is going to ask white some
questions about how he wants to break up
the center
Bishop C5 first with his forces let's
play C3 which is not what you want and I
mean if you allowed the night before in
the night to enter the D3 that's going
to be all sorts of Havoc to wreak
oh what a risky move by Lavon wait a
minute but very important that he has
Bishop E3 in response to a Check Yes but
I've also got like Queen A5 check ideas
so you can combine the two whoa I'm
gonna combine this
oh and Bishop five next so I think white
ass play Move like Queen C3 I think not
give time
yep and it doesn't look like Hikaru is a
clear follow-up here we need seven
Edition F5 but you can just Castle
yeah I feel like night before was was um
a little bit impulsive and I think you
go Bishop G5 here right you have to keep
the bishop keep the bishop pair nff six
then you can take on D5 with check that
networks and maybe even second exchange
only one
that would get
very interesting
um of a rook see when I I felt like 93
would would be just fine for black
and then Bishop E4
yeah that really takes the wind out of
what sails I feel like maybe he had to
just gamble with Bishop G5 I really
don't know if that was sound or not
but compared to this I I would take that
any day whoa that is a risky move but I
think it works out
because Knight C4 there's Bishop takes
C4 and the queen is hanging
right but you could still play Knights I
would probably I mean actually it really
is optional I think all roads lead to
the same outcome I feel with this uh you
know symmetrical Pawn structure and
black having the C file and no real
weakness
yeah let's see what Hikaru comes up with
here
um
Queen can move
to see seminal so he just drops back to
E6 kind of playing it solidly
I don't see why winning this game though
it's just too symmetrical
yeah it's hard to believe maybe I don't
know you try and move like G3 if you get
an H4
might be something
like a rookie five or a queen a five but
might be trying something himself on the
king side
Queen B1 Rook C1 a lot of weak light
squares Lavon simply cannot afford to
lose this game
oh no absolutely not at least hold the
draw and you'll get another chance in
the three minute portion to bring it
down to four
uh is there something to be said
yeah about trying to exchange Queens
here with Queen E5 ah but there's always
Rook 2 and Rook B1 so it's just not
I mean there's never anything
yep
yeah the queen side pawns are too tender
there
a lot of shuffling going on here it's
just seems like a totally even end game
but Hikaru probably still thinking about
trying to get Lavon down on the clock
and playing for a win yeah he might
really drag this on a while
um see six minutes on the matchbook so I
think we will get we definitely will see
another game but now Vaughn really
thinking about this I don't know what is
he thinking about
seven seconds he's setting himself and
setting himself up for failure again why
didn't he take on D5 there simply If he
if he was worried
yeah because that's an insta draw
I guess or and White's not even risking
there now Hikaru has some pressure going
on oh man I'm getting concerned Rook C1
okay you got you've got rookie one back
probably have to
now we saw Hikaru overzealous a couple
of games ago he can make a draw here in
a variety of ways but I think once again
he's gonna try to press here
yeah I don't know if he has a seven move
here though yeah there is 57 hanging on
to the pond but this time I guess okay
I think he's learned his oh no he has
not learned this lesson he wants to
teach Levon a lesson
maybe he just wants to bleed out the
mask like I don't think he feels he's
better here
that too of course
but he's too enticed by lavon's clock
could enter
sloppy mobiki car now he just says I'm
bailing out but the King enters F4
ah this should be five Bishop C6 drawing
but he doesn't have enough he doesn't
have enough here I guess there's no
break yeah you try G4 but that still
doesn't amount to anything
he's still going and
your car just has to avoid a bad
pre-move
right yeah there's never any zoos when
the bishop always has just a free Square
well this is just Confident pre-moving
by Nakamura and he can go Bishop F5 if
Levon is not careful so time to repeat
yes I see Cara gonna bleed out more
[__]
dancing how is it not a three-fold yet
I don't understand how that's possible
no but he's gonna wait his 10 seconds
out and then play a move
and ensuring that the next game is going
to be the last
yes why'd uh I mean quite a merry-go
around there both sides I think we're
trying to win at some point but draw The
Logical result
okay so a pivotal game to finish off the
three-point segment it's a five-point
lead currently
can Lavon score a much-needed Victory
with the black pieces he's trying to do
that with another Sicilian Queen takes
D4 I feel like is there yeah I mean
first of all I want to commend Lavon for
at least trying the Sicilian and you
know something more energetic than a
solid you know e45 line
but it didn't work out for him the first
time around maybe yeah we're gonna say
something along the lines of B5 at some
point B5 B4 I was going to say something
that's not worth repeating I'm just
gonna point out that Knight D5 is an
idea but then I noticed that it doesn't
carry a threat A and B at blunder's A2
so
that would not contribute to the uh
uh to the to the conversation in a
productive way
now Lavon Ein Knight C4 potentially oh I
love The Rook H3 though supporting that
history night
I like what lavon's doing on the queen
side though Knight C4 typical Sicilian
attacking moves and B5 could come next
he's better I think practically at least
well I mean the moment you mentioned
Knight D5 that's what I've been looking
at uh for the last few
seconds can you get away with it like 85
85 95 I guess it's convenient that Lavon
places Queen on A6
yep
now King B1 here is a possibility but
you've always got to reckon with the the
idea of Discovery now as long as the
Knight defends the queen you're good
Lavon wants to attack with his pawns
though
wait a second
Queen back to B8 maybe simply I am
surprised well I guess we're willing to
give up Bishops for Knights here if he
can
put some pressure on the D6 one but it
seems unlikely
boy was that night a good piece though
yeah Knight D5 now seems to lack the
luster right to produce any serious
chances like we'll be able to take and
sidestep the King
okay so B4 is obviously very likely to
be the next move for black
whoa Queen H5 that is really right field
and on beef literally oh I guess he he
might want this Knight D5 now
oh because he's targeting F7 Lavon
making a calm developing move love
Bishop E7 but hang on 95 is very very
tempting to me
you wouldn't be hang on Tanya 95 yeah
yeah you will be pinned along the key
file I mean I'm trying to make work I
guess it didn't
he's trying to make it work Castle's 95
man it's funny how 95 is now suddenly
like the main idea
but I guess Lavon can leave his King in
the middle maybe yeah and play Bishop F6
but then the Rook stubble on the default
can't take your eyes off with the d-pawn
either
aha
yeah yeah still still very tricky maybe
G6 then just so I can go B4
great call and now it's time for B4
maybe you can start with A4
in order to be able to push the pawn to
A3 once the A and B pawns disappear oh
that is attractive
I think lavon's gonna do just that maybe
that's what he's thinking about okay he
plays B4 and then A4 huh
same thing
okay big chance here for him
yeah this will certainly be the last
game in the portion Queen B4 big threat
of A3
yes sir
that Rook on each three is doing a good
job of
controlling critical squares
all right E5
um so
this just looks this has got to be
losing for white but the car trying to
generate activity in the center
and his King is still pretty safe for
the time being so maybe it's time for A3
it is so messy yeah I like A3 I also
like the move Rook H4 that exists
getting a Tempo on the queen and
potentially maneuvering the other group
now you can combine the two and play A3
now but the question is what's the
follow-up after B3 there's tactics with
Bishop A4 you know just trying to use
her on the queen side also Rook H to C4
as you said midday night if you're
considered here yeah that would be my
pick bingo
well one's pick is Queen back I don't
know about that
a bit slow I like my queen on B6
attacking B2
yeah I think if it ain't broke you don't
have to fix it and that Queen is
misplaced on C7
and E4 is the move I wanna play but I
have to evaluate the consequences of 95.
like Bishop B5 even C4 which could get
really chaotic now everyone's about to
watch the H file yes well pointed out
and we're in here we go with this again
mode where Lavon down to 34 seconds
Bishop F6 circumspect though oh if I
take 25 it should be five okay
oh
so chaotic here and that rookie yeah
generating chances Rook would be
overloaded that's why I played C3
the other Knight can also jump into the
game via before
yes I think it's Lavon just keeps it
well I'm so worried about his clock
though under 20 seconds
and there the position is not resolved
at all okay
[Music]
but it does exchange I mean it does help
him a little bit get those Queens off
the board
I get what he's doing but I really feel
like he car the worst is almost behind
him here and now it's just an unclear
end game
yeah it does feel like and we know he's
simplifying oh don't allow Knight D6
oh
because then you lose the D3 Pawn
okay but still but still it's even
material
somehow it's even material Lavon is
better but King B1 and rookie three if
rookie two
yes okay or this oh this is and there
could be some potential danger that
planet A4 is loose
but the car is just kind of setting for
a draw here makes sense considering the
match score
make a move Luan
oh wait one second why is he thinking so
long just move
and if anything the Knight is always
such a dangerous piece no reason for
Hikaru to milk the clock there's no gain
from that
because the clock isn't ticking right I
think the car really is trying to win
this position okay Lavon wait there was
okay D5 yeah there was potential for D5
but
besides uh
don't blunder a fork
actually either side can motor a fork
but especially black
oh
okay
it should be
should be under control oh wait a second
92 though oh my God it almost feels like
you're losing against the car even wait
there's no oh no G3 no
I thought so too but Hikaru going around
again I think he might win this oh that
would be sickening
it that's a great word to describe it
that would actually be sickening
okay I think it's time to
yeah
or not always going the other way no but
can use for King G6 so you don't want to
venture too far
the problem is when you've got this
against the car your hands are shaking
because you just know that you can lose
it at any moment but Lavon doing a great
job here of holding the fort
yeah
and now I mean Hikaru needs to make sure
he doesn't get his Night Trap somehow
yep because the pawn end game is losing
for white because of the superior King
position and finally no Lavon yeah okay
now it's a repetition
and that's all she wrote in the
three-minute segment
okay this one's gonna be aborted and
Jeffrey a five-point lead remains for
Hikaru Nakamura far from a blowout and
the match is far from over
but just a commanding lead and he's been
in control ever since the opening
seconds of the match
and I would actually argue that it helps
Hikaru to know what Lavon is capable of
um based on that on Drake match so
there's not going to be any sort of
sleepwalking through this portion
thinking that the match is over he won't
underestimate Lavon and that should Bode
very well for him in the bullet
it certainly should he's going to take
him with the utmost seriousness uh and
Lavon once again he needs an absolute
miracle and we will see if he can pull
it off now before we go on break we
wanted to remind you that you should get
ready for the quarter four 2022 state of
chess.com coming to you live on December
21st we have some huge news for the
chess community and the event will be
followed by a Community Q a with Danny
wrench plus some very special guests
will be joining the show to talk about
the exciting announcements we're making
and what these announcements entail for
the future of the chess Community do not
miss this show mark your calendars for
December 21st at 10 A.M Pacific 1 p.m
Eastern Time right here on twitch.tv
slash chess well we hope you have your
calendars marked uh for the one plus one
portion which is coming right up here at
the speed Chess Championship we will be
back with more Nakamura Iranian action
in just a little while
[Music]
thank you
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship hikara Nakamura facing off
LaVon aronian in a fascinating round of
eight match GM Jeffrey Zhang GM Daniel
nerdinski bringing you coverage of
today's match as we take a quick look at
the overall prize pool and the prize
distribution these are amazingly
generous prizes Jeffrey we've been over
this many times but it's such a great
time to be alive if you're a chess fan
and if you're a chess player never have
players been able to do as well from the
comfort of their own homes
oh man we I mean we honestly live such a
luxury I myself could not have imagined
uh the state of Chess where it is right
now like five years back and just you
know to be able to make a living from
playing chess at the comfort of your
room Homestead just to take the words
from you is just really a nice feeling
it is indeed and Hikaru Nakamura must
have a nice feeling he holds an 11-6
lead against Levon aronian who has kept
who has kept it I wouldn't say close
he's prevented Hikaru from pulling away
entirely and we've seen quite The
Comebacks this year in the SEC in the
bullet segment but nobody has made a
comeback past three points Lavon needs
to start winning early and Jeffrey he
basically has zero margin for Aaron
Hikaru of course is the worst kind of
guy to try to make this comeback against
oh yeah yes all those points zero margin
for error as Lavon I think the best
chances to you know take it one game at
a time it only takes one to really start
your run and get maybe a car rattled
early on he does switch to a London
let's see what he has in store for us
okay a lot of moves being rattled out
that B7 Pawn is usually pretty
Untouchable due to night before which
Levon prevents
okay I like this you know and and he
surprised all of us against Dimitri by
playing ridiculously fast in the opening
he's got to repeat that here
he does I like to move like E3 maybe
Knight B2 you threatened B for that
night could get caught on the edge of
the board
um soon
yeah and Hikaru trying to remedy that by
opening up an escape Square for his
Knight but instead advances to C4 and
might try to follow it up with a check
on A5
but B3 oh we need five I would even be
considering to play like a bomb Cloud
move can you do just to keep the knights
on the board we may see a team move here
totally possible because B3 is a massive
threat but this kind of plays into
hikaru's hands
uh in terms of forcing a Time Scramble
now before I guess Lavon wants queen B3
uh Bishop C2 almost works there but it
does well B3 Queen C3 Queen takes A2 but
I don't think that works
oh my goodness that is wait a second
line okay he goes to me it doesn't allow
it Bishop C2 anyway would be hilarious
he takes B1 he almost played it
wait but now Bishop takes C4 maybe
Intermezzo I don't know
yeah he's gonna allow the haunts if
you're in A2 but I think he regains it
immediately after Rook A1
and then Black's gonna be in a tough
spot on the queen side with a really big
weakness on C6 right here yeah I don't
know if you take an A2 or take on C4
first but if you can plant that Rook on
A6 you would have tremendous play on The
Queen side
no this is a big chance in game one for
Lavon Hikaru preventing The Rook from
advancing past A4 but now 95 is a huge
threat
okay and Lavon can pick up this Pawn at
his leisure yes with rookie for any time
he chooses now
yeah now's a good time he's up upon he's
got winning chances
Ken Lavon carry this forward and convert
this into an extra point he has to win
this game
I don't know about the Rook trade though
I think it's still okay just play yeah
E4 don't go King D3
right now somebody's got to find the
right Central breaks it's not clear to
me what it what is uh oh and he's opened
up the king side and hikaru's activated
his Rook I don't like the way this is
going for Lamont at all oh man he can
take on G3
they got a five H the H Pawn starts
running I think you take the bishop and
take the pawn to try to go after the C
Pawn But Here Comes hikaru's age fast is
this winning for black
uh oh it might be he has to address the
pawn but then cd5
okay Rook A8 a prudent move
six just King D6 or this both pawns
might promote
King D6 e takes D5 defense C6 and we
might get some sort of a fortress
Hikaru is defending this so well
I'm not talking about that I thought he
could have simplified her I thought
you're gonna simplified it easier but he
is going to take on D5 next
it's gonna be a draw well Rook H6 still
or is it no no this is defensible yes
the king should be well placed enough
yeah and if you're Lavon do you offer a
draw here and if I do decline it do you
decline it
knowing Hikaru he will yeah he's gonna
keep the Rooks on the board the com the
comparison I've made earlier Jeffrey I
think you'll appreciate this is in an
American football game when you avoid
making the touchdown because you're
leading and you want to avoid giving the
other team the ball even though you're
quote unquote worse
and now if you have six I mean he can
play this on for another two minutes
oh and that's huge and Lebon has to
force the draw here if you're Lavon you
push the pawn you force the Rooks off
the board
and you basically Force Hikaru to repeat
moves which he doesn't have to do check
to as possible
oh my God he is he has taken five
minutes off the clock in game one
five minutes
but I guess he's content with allowing
this repetition
but yeah that is a ton of time going
away and another big Miss for Lavon I
mean he cannot afford even a single more
one of these misses in what was a
borderline winning end game
oh for sure yeah he just had a clean
Pawn up couldn't figure out the right
ways to move forward and or manages to
salvage another one this is a nice I
like this approach from lavondo you have
to create Chances with these kinds of uh
offbeat systems
plenty of time left for a comeback but
he needs to start winning right about
now
is he dropping the E5 and I guess there
was rookie a h
okay he's unbalancing the game which I
really like but Queen A4 looked oh no no
no no yeah yeah D3 was still hanging
sorry about that similar narrative to
the last game except this time Lavon
with the uh oh no yeah this is very
unpleasant this is actually a total
positional nightmare just look at the
light scores in the center and that
Bishop on f8 just a passive spectator
this is right up hikara's alley he wins
100 of the time in these types of
positions oh yeah A5 another clinical
move stopping any sort of Knight V6
ideas you can leave the Knight on C4 you
can bring the other one over to D5 just
an absolute disaster for Lavon
Rook to D5 maybe there's Knight F6 so
you want to be
You Want To Tread cautiously if you're
white but you can just preserve the
status quo as long as you want waiting
for the opportunity to cash in
yes and he's doing just that with rookie
one at some point I do want to maneuver
the other Knight around
I'm not sure how exactly
maybe now Knight ft2 on the next move
that ft2 does that allow Rook d8 but
worst case you've got F3 yeah Lavon
doing a good job so far he's activating
his Knight can he take on e4 hang on
yeah was this a slight Bluff I'm not
sure what oh there's 95 Knight C7 with
the four ah there is
okay but it seems that lavon's making
some progress in terms of activating his
pieces hikar probably fine with a drop
but he goes for it
now I think still you stabilized it
enough that I mean this powerful knight
on C4 and also the pawn on B6 against
pawn and B7 long term could spell danger
for black
oh absolutely you're gonna go after it
with your Knights this I'm very
pessimistic about lavon's chances here
in this game
yeah six allows Queen D5 now Knight D6
is a huge threat
and yeah I couldn't bring anything at
once
and this is going to be another
incredibly long game
ink G5 though objectively it should be
close to a fortress now once you put the
Knight on C6
or is it the space for his King to get
to C4 and maybe maneuver the other night
or I mean you could try oh
man that is huge
five making all sorts of inroads into
Black's position this is almost zuke's
one
yeah why is it point eight it's point
eight that's such a misleading email you
can actually give up the seatbelt and
put your knight right back on C6 oh
cause you can't defend A5 this is
phenomenal defense by LeBron so far but
we know how this ends it's only a matter
of time before Hikaru force is a mistake
so hard to keep up four seconds oh wait
a second
oh there's no 96.
so you might have to force a draw here
yeah Hikaru quite invisibly annoyed with
himself
is there another way to try I don't see
it
But ultimately he's taken another four
minutes off the match clock
so it's a successful result like if he
draws all the games he wins the race by
Five Points yeah it's not it's not
exactly the worst outcome ever
oh far from it and it's another super
long game he's gonna milk the rest of
his clock down
and make a draw
yeah close but no cigar there for Hikaru
but yeah for Lavon now he's got to get
some wins nine minutes off the match
clock he's made zero progress
and yeah I keep saying it he's got to
start winning now he's got to start
winning now he really has to start
winning now because he doesn't have much
time left
this is going to be another very dry
opening position after Bishop 394 I
presume or even drier now that white
doesn't even get the bishop there
yeah another one of those Petrov Berlin
type of structures
that both of these players are so
familiar with Lavon trying to play
aggressively but C6 and D5 is just super
watertight for black maybe you go see
through Bishop C2 that's the only idea I
see but black can always put their
Knight and F6 of just really leads to
nowhere
yep
no this is it's clear what a car's
strategy is get these solid positions
milk the clock down make sure every game
takes between you know four and five
minutes
and chill
yeah just nothing to write home about
for Lavon try C4
good try
keep keep some spice Alive Now can you
go like 93 I want to open the bishop
with D5 at some point but still
liquidating Knight A5 interesting okay
but does this actually produce anything
concrete if black just takes on D5
and goes Knight C5 B4
but now the Knight gets really jumpy and
White's pieces are falling apart when
d8's coming oh man Rook theater we're
also Knight of four potentially
absolutely
okay that was a good find
great move by LeBron opening up two
attacks on the night
so now Knight to five Queen D5 oh well
there there is a G6 like G4 always Queen
G5
for example and worst case you can drop
the bishop back to E6 if you're worried
about the pin oh you do I know
yeah I feel like there should be a good
way to simplify into another drawish and
game yeah wow this is quite the match
strategy for Hikaru just make a draw in
every bullet game
you might be getting more here this it
is annoying on the the default lavon's
gonna sack a queen no but that was just
that was a terrible decision by Lavon
because not only is this going to take a
while he has no winning chances in the
resulting position oh man I could see
another five minutes coming off
oh definitely and I could see hikar
winning this game
objectively it should still be a
fortress that you keep your Rook on the
third rank you make sure the black king
can't walk in
but I mean you could really just play
this on forever yeah in theory it should
be an easy draw but in practice there's
like you can make the right pawn moves
at the right moment F6 G4
so easy to forget about a pin or
misplace your Rook or allow the
opponent's skin to get to H3 so let's
see how Hikaru tries to squeeze the win
out here
right at some moment King H5 or F5 is
gonna be played
maybe here it is not yet it goes F5
first but that's four
mm-hmm
potentially F4 now but then white will
take and go Rook F3 I think yes he's
still got it under control but it's
dicey
F1 Rook D3
yep and the key is to keep all of your
pieces on defense now don't forget
uh-huh I was wondering if I could go
after the A5 Pond there but maybe too
much another idea is to trade into a
pawn end game give up the queen for the
rook in the night and Black's King is
more active so Lavon has to keep an eye
on that as well
yeah I think he's done a good thing
though maybe you can even walk his King
up because there's a good configuration
listen if he wins the A4 Pawn he's going
to start playing for a win so he cars
suddenly on his back foot a little bit
right Queen E2 Knight D4 is it a blunder
oh I was about to propose that
and easy to blunder for white as well
settling the pieces are very loose oh
now is there a Queenie too I guess you'd
still have the night before night before
yep and now the pawn cannot be defended
whoa
yeah Lavon might try here as you said
he should but the positive for Hikaru is
that prolongs the game by another three
minutes I mean this game is taking a
ridiculous amount of time off the magic
we're at we're at the halfway point and
we've only played two games
crazy yeah I mean Lavon Lavon might have
to pray for some kind of night for
because yeah this could go on and on and
on start pushing
but can you keep pushing and F3 needs to
be protected at all times this is still
a drop Knight C3 is actually making some
progress you go a five
foreign the problem is it's so easy to
miss a fork if you're white if you over
push you overextend your pieces and wait
a second I really like how he's don't
take yeah you couldn't take there there
was Queen C1
your car will gonna keep checking oh on
the floor I think
oh 95. make a move oh my God no wrong
way slip um
Knight C3
oh my lands
and Lavon Just Smiles I mean I think he
definitely saw Knight C3 but I mean
you're just Panic like your hand was
probably shaking for for the last 20 30
moves and that just happens
yeah it doesn't matter how many bonds
white wins it's just an easier position
to play for black because he's got the
queen he's got the checks
and now it has officially gotten
basically out of hand with 15 and a half
left on the match clock Lavon literally
has to be perfect the rest of the way
yeah and he's not perfect he's losing
the way a car is dragging it out I don't
even know if you can get six games
no we've gotten through
15 minutes
I mean think about that for a second
yeah let that sink in and just crazy
and levano the disaster of an opening
here Bishop C2 Queen D3 comes to mind
also H4 you can shatter the structure
and levana's a good bullet player
Jeffrey I think I think it's safe to say
you know if you're competitive against
sikara like this he's a great bullet
player but that slight lack of
experience that slight lack of speed oh
Bishop G5 look at this look at this oh
an F7 falling
and you do not want this in a bullet
game he smells blood here I think you
have to Rook a fit and then he's just
gonna I don't think he's even gonna take
on D7 maybe he'll just lift up his Rook
add more fuel to the fire rookie 3 looks
like a fantastic move yeah similar idea
just brings stuff into the game
now in F3 I mean okay now he decides to
take I guess he wants to open the D file
with D5
or DC
both looked so tempting not a fate
Lawan attempting to hold it together I
like this
now D6 and queen F3 it's one idea can
also oh Bishop four threatening maybe D6
or Bishop C6
rookie 8 also in the mix at some point
because the Knight is immobilized
okay now Lavon making some progress
yeah he needs to block the Deep one
though don't allow D6 he did have the
move Bishop FC yeah D4 yes Bishop D4
seemed good
he's allowed a car to get his Rook into
the game now it's clear that White's
Advantage is evaporated but it's anybody
yeah it is razor sharp Rook of three
Queen D6 so D7 wow taking advantage of
the fact black can't take
wait now he's got a win I think Rook D4
and queen D no oh
those are deers that's the move what is
G3 which is apparently the movie because
yes the queen must leave and then oh my
God unbelievably cold-blooded forcing
the Queen off and now Lebon loses again
rookie eight rookie eight and just Rook
have four friends or where do you go
actually
no he's literally playing this like an
engine Queen E3 I guess
oh man or maybe just Rook F4 also wins
Rook of four covering all the exits
Queen F3
don't blunder mate on E2
oh wait wait a second six Super clever
defensive resource by Lavon
how do you avoid the checks here is
Queen B3 you don't you fly yeah the
queen will just Slither itself in
just insane just insane
and he's doing it again he's pulling
away and when you're playing Hikaru this
just always seems to happen unless your
name is Magnus Carlson
really does and yeah it's probably
officially in the books nicaro yeah
explain some funny
opening now
yeah he's let himself relax a little bit
and explore some new opening territory
but he makes lemonade out of lemons I
think he's got a great position out of
the opening again
practically in the house some way yeah
well I'm gonna try to put the now in F3
at least he controls the G5 squared
maybe their attacking chances down the
road
LeBron's only chance now is to win in
the boxing says we can exactly oh B4
he's tilting he's tilting it's all
falling apart 94. Bishop F5 Bishop oh
okay gotta watch out for Rook G6 there
oh there's rockitch
wait Ricky since the queen would get
trapped so he goes rookie oh Knight f66
I think he missed Knight G5 there and
suddenly the attack becomes
insurmountable oh because there's Knight
H7 on Rook HG
and now uh-huh Rook hate
oh he blunders again
he just gives up the exchange
oh my goodness the car found another way
out um
he just goes from winning to losing it
doesn't even go through equality you
know it's like FM to GM
yeah no just nothing in between
Queen G5 this is a ridiculous tactics
here and the reason he played F3 was to
pin the Knight so that you can't play
Knight takes C4 with Tempo here oh my
God how does he see that
instantly
now is there even a way to deal with
this F4 Knight F4
no there's just nothing
all sorts of discoveries at his disposal
Rook H5 no then you take on G5 with
check so watch out
I guess you go just Queenie fire Queen
F5 yeah this works
I mean takes 62 Bishop F5 even the
simple simple move ends it
and everything's pinned
H5
okay
easy enough
and another one in the can for Nakamura
and I stand corrected I thought the
bullet was going to be competitive but
he's pulled away entirely here
that third game yeah I mean I guess
Lavon did have a couple of chances early
on but since that Hikaru has been
storming
and now lovana super tilts it and I
think the the first game honestly was
the turning point I would argue Jeffrey
because there Lavon had his best chance
he had a winning end game he wins that
game it's a four-point match and that is
far from reassuring
that game draws it takes five minutes
off the clock and it's just so
frustrating to have to do that again and
again when you're playing Hikaru
yeah I totally agree that felt like the
Backbreaker
um well some of the Vons managed to get
a reasonable position on this I thought
he was tilted out of the opening it was
like pre-moving E6 C6 and V6 but
suddenly he's doing pretty well again
it was H5 looks risky
I guess he's gonna follow that up with
g609 F6
Queen E3
yeah wow well for a car I think you can
just
put a knight on G5 it'll be uncontested
there what's the E5 why is he shaking
his head I mean you're up by eight yeah
he's not he wants to be up by 15 I guess
he wants to get a better position out of
the opening in this game
but it looks like he's got a better
position now
yeah I'm looking at some sort of G4 just
really opening all the floodgates to the
king
I think he wants number one bullet also
like he's definitely thinking about it
just accomplishing everything
this is where the commentator has to
recuse himself from the conversation
Rook D7
it's very close here but Richards met
with Rick she said maybe you play H6
here he wants to bring the other Rook
Lavon running to E7 he's carved out a
little pathway with his Rooks but H6 is
in the mix
right those age spots could actually
become Queens if black doesn't play this
correctly okay
your car has taken his foot off the gas
pedal here yeah this should be a win for
Lavon he's got enough time I feel
maybe just King F7
I don't know about that idea now he's
giving him connected passers which is
always dangerous even if they're
restrained right I don't know how
convincing is this King G4 and H5
uh-oh uh oh Lavon is just giving Hikaru
activities handing it to him
H6 Maybe
but maybe you still play H7 because
you can penetrate along the f file with
Rook H2
King G8
is a possibility if you want to stop the
pawn
right
that is a huge move yeah not blundering
any H7 ideas okay now Lavon should win
it but it's still not over because the
car is very close to all these Pawns
yeah there's like Rook D7
oh yeah King E7 this should be good
enough now
this might be the lowest amount of
bullet games you're gonna end up playing
like they've gone five games and it's
almost over
yeah hey Cara's gonna it's gonna take
its sweet time here yet again
oh yeah he's gotten every game into the
Super drawn out end game
and he can build up a minute on his
clock and when he's and and milk out
another minute wait what is Lavon doing
I think he just got impatient there
draw
you might lose this like that I was
literally opening my mouth to say that
A6 already threatens a win
oh
okay three Rook B7 is a draw
yep just a fortress no way to make
progress but if you move your king you
allow King B3 and you lose
right so where do you go but this looks
King C5 I'm not sure what was the right
move there
yeah it was hard to defend practically
I mean it is winning but it's gonna take
time forever yeah the car is gonna milk
so much time here this is crazy
crazy this is only the sixth game in the
portion yeah we might only see like two
more after this
we might see less bullet games than than
uh three plus one games which has got to
be rare even though there's obviously
less time to play bullet
for sure don't go B4 there was a mate
there
all right yeah he's gonna go for the
typical Ventura setup
yeah game B1 B2 build a bridge
oh my God this game is still going
and he might I mean he might really
play till May like even when Lavon
promotes if you want to maximize your
drawing chance or your your milking time
you build up 30 more seconds on your
clock and then sit
so we're not even close to this game
being over enough how much time has it
already been five minutes plus
at least yeah I'm mesmerized I'm
mesmerized by how much time he's taking
off of the clock with each game and
levonis and the game is still going yeah
the game is still going
Rook A6 Rook A6 King C1 and King A1 yes
he's not actually progressing don't make
a three foot all right he finally finds
the idea King B3 King A1 wins on the
spot
But Here We Go Again
take it yeah play that oh my God
build up some time on the clock and keep
on milking another minute off the clock
unbelievable
is struggling you made him
oh my God what are you doing laughs
oh I think Lavon honestly doesn't mind
uh
playing fewer games either oh this is
ridiculous he's gonna take another 30
seconds off the clock
yeah this might actually be the
penultimate game
this might be the longest bullet game in
SEC history
I think it is Jeffrey I think this took
six minutes off the match clock
did we start at 10 yeah there might have
been 10 minutes I think there was like
nine something yeah oh my gosh
this is brutal
and Lavon is just smiling incredulously
so we are going to see a record low
because if my memory serves me right
it's normally like an average of 27 28
games but
probably going to be 24 at the end which
is incredibly low
yeah
and he played with nine seconds left so
the card doesn't complete his strategy
okay now
it's fun time
it's party time
and the match is over
yeah I saw his car using this A5 A4 run
it up in his uh disrespect speed runs
let's see if it works on the Vaughn he's
got it it's actually got a pretty decent
position I must say
Hikaru is streaming I believe
you mean he's streaming the match live
or the match live so it's a it's a
disrespect speed run against irony
wow
okay this the way the match has gone
this will be the last game of the
portion but given how sharp the position
is we might say a resolution a little
bit faster than usual
right yeah I mean if they get another
end game it'll certainly be the last
game
but can Levon made him he's gonna try
with that four
no why does White's got to be winning
here this is not a picture of the base
games Rook F6 well
yeah Rook F6
eh I think he'll still fight here
oh yeah
oh yeah why did Lavon
got to trade the Queens
yes he's content with having to pass
your a pawn you can still cut
now he's gonna past age fun so this
should be
reasonably
I mean comfortable win
Nakamura isn't going to be happy with
this bullet or anything after the match
but
this has just been all dominance all
Hikaru really since the
the second half of the five minute
portion I would argue
yes
I mean I don't even remember where this
match got away from Lavon I think he
started Owen two
got back within one but yeah those last
two games in the five minutes segment is
where I would pinpoint
um the match getting out of hand in a
way
it was a wire to wire Victory as you
said
and you know yeah he definitely had his
chances throughout the five minute
portion he came a little bit close there
was a time in the three minute portion
when I think Levon got it down a four
and he had chances to bring it down to
three but Hikaru was so good at allowing
at preventing his opponents from gaining
any kind of momentum as I said earlier
and he does it again here he can milk
out the rest of the match clock with
this game and any any I think he will
and he might win suddenly he's like
better
yeah this a pawn not going anywhere
after Rook a three
how do you draw this for white
I didn't even notice how this got bad
for Lavon I mean it was just up a pawn
right now he's losing yeah it seemed
like a position he could never lose but
the car that's just that's just a
challenge
yep exactly okay seven and King F5 and
he's gonna keep milking this
okay
Etc
foreign
got short on time outside of that one
early game I think in the five minute
portion which he found a way just he
never had enough time to convert his
advantages simple as that
we're gonna get a rook versus Rook a
trade oh okay Hikaru does not need to be
doing this because there's no more time
on the match clock
just to be safe I guess
yeah since he is streaming I think he
just okay he checked the match clock he
repeats the moves
and the match is officially over the
final score is 15 and a half to eight
and a half a seven point victory for
Hikaru and it was never really in
question Jeffrey was it
no not at all from the get-go the car
opened that match with the two-point
lead never let it go it was never even
tied
the wire to wire Victory and he is the
second player to move on to the
semi-finals
and the games themselves were close I
mean the games themselves were close
they were incredibly entertained
super fun match
but I think if we had to pinpoint one
area where Hikaru really asserted his
dominance across the time controls
it was in the arena of time scrambles
like almost every time scramble key won
regardless of the valuation right
exactly and I seem to remember this the
one five minute game where Lavon I think
was up a rook for like Five Pawns
and Hikaru even managed to not only draw
that position but Win It And since then
I mean it's just hard not to get rattled
as Levon and matches filed from there
it did indeed and we will have an
interview with the winner with Hikaru
Nakamura uh he will be offering his
thoughts on this super entertaining
Majesty car was officially into the
semi-finals he's our second
semi-finalist after nihal sarin so
ladies and gentlemen another speed Chess
Championship Match is in the books but
don't go anywhere because we will have
Hikaru Nakamura in the studio to share
his thoughts on the other side of this
short break stay tuned
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship and we have the winner of
today's match Grandmaster Hikaru
Nakamura is in the studio for a quick
interview Hikaru congratulations on a
very resounding Victory could you start
by sharing a general thoughts on how you
played and on the trajectory of the
match
it's like five or six games were very
competitive and then Levon kind of fell
apart at the end of five plus one and I
mean after that I mean I mean there's
just a waste of everybody's time because
there was really no coming back
um so yeah it really just came down to
maybe the five plus one portion after
that I mean what what to say it just
wasn't meant to be for Lavon so I'm
happy obviously
yeah I would also like to say my
congrats to our very very convincing
stuff
um from the start so yeah you talk a
little bit about that five minute
portion and would you pinpoint like the
turning point where it really started to
go downhill for Lavon the one game where
I think you were up a rook or you were
down to Rook for for Five Pawns that
game uh the moment you lost that would
you say that was actually the end of the
match well I mean that's when I won I
was that the game was that the game when
I was up three and a half two and a half
so I know I won two at the end but I
wasn't sure if that you were up by two
it was I think you were up four and a
half two and a half that was the last
one uh so oh so that was the last game
the five plus one yeah I mean probably
like the the game before in that game
was really sort of the nail on the
coffin I mean to be fair though in that
game uh where he had to work for the
Five Pawns I was also completely winning
and I messed it up by allowing this E6
and all the counter play
um so it could have been different too
but I really it was just the five plus
one I mean once um I was up by three I I
think five percent was objectively where
Lavon probably probably have the best
chances overall um I mean whenever we
whenever we got low on time I just
seemed to outplay him and we were in
those scrambles five seconds on the
clock uh I mean I was just better than
him so really it was simply the five
song where he had the best chance when
he wasn't able to keep it close to five
plus one I mean the rest was just smooth
sailing so yeah it was really as simple
as just those two games probably when I
was up three and a half two and a half
winning those final two
oh and actually wait three and a half
two and a half was wait wait it was
three and a half two and off where I had
where I played Rook takes C4 is that the
game where I I love that whole Rook take
C4 F6 thing
the crazy it was a crazy sequence where
you sack an exchange yeah the one with
work C4 F6 is one with Bishop G4 and
Rook C5 right
exactly yeah yeah so I mean yeah that
game was very critical too because I
mean I that game probably I should not
have won either I mean that probably
should have been should have been a um
should have been a drop so yeah those
last two games with five plus one that
was that was really all there was to it
it's just that simple
um and yeah when I won those two games I
mean obviously in three plus one Lavon
had some chances too I mean I thought it
was a very sloppy floppy match from you
know from there on by both of us but
again like I said I think it was pretty
clear what the direction was going to be
so that happens
mm-hmm Hikaru if you had to only keep
one time control is it fair to say that
the three plus one time control is where
you feel most comfortable asserting your
dominance
you know I don't I don't know it's funny
because every time I play these playing
the SEC somehow I really enjoy the five
plus one like for example I think I when
I played photo say maybe last or two
years ago I crushed him in the five plus
one and it's weird because I really
enjoy playing flyable song where you can
think you can get down like a minute on
the clock like I do a lot of things that
I normally don't do in three plus one or
one plus one because I'm trying to play
good chess
um so it I really like the five plus one
objectively
um but in terms of what I think is my my
best control I would have to say it's
probably I mean I would say it's one
plus one the thing is though the one
plus one like these two matches there's
really I mean there's been nothing to
play for so it's kind of hard to stay
motivated I mean the magic that's
probably and Lavon today I mean it sort
of like just get to the end of the match
as opposed to try and uh run up the
score so
um I mean I like all the time controls
mm-hmm we have one feature chat question
before we let you go dagenge 13 asks
sicaro how do you feel about nihal's
performance thus far in the SCC and
about facing him next up
um well I haven't really seen much of
his match but I think I caught a little
bit of his imaginess on each like the
last two games before they went to the
uh the four game tiebreaker so I caught
the last two or three games of that
that's that's pretty much all that I've
seen um I did play Knee Hall in India
obviously so I am aware of you know
aware of his talent and obviously
watching cgc as well so it should be a
fun match
um and I'm just looking forward to it so
we'll see how it goes
fantastic well Hikaru will let you go
have a great rest of your stream and
congratulations on the match victory
thank you guys have a good one
all right well that's that Hikaru
Nakamura in the studio and on his a game
today Jeffrey as he wins by seven points
and as he said I mean he was just kind
of treading water in the bullet
um not to suggest he wasn't playing well
but the match really was decided uh in
that three-minute portion
yeah it really was and I think it's
amazing how confident he was it was only
up by three in the five minute but he
basically said that that was that so
yeah just a really really uh huge way to
go into the semifinals and that will be
a barn burner of a matchup uh against
the hall oh that is gonna be I mean so
mouth-watering let's take a quick look
at our bracket we have our first two
semi-finalists who will be facing each
other Hikaru and nihal just a classic
one for the ages and this is why we all
love the SCC
um and we have yet to determine the
second semi-final matchup but before we
even get there we have two absolutely
mouth-watering matchups for you uh
Carlson carwana and Wesley mvl Jeffrey I
mean what more could you possibly ask
for out of the SEC oh my goodness I mean
a rematch of the world championship
match that went down to the wire
that's it's like plenty of riches right
now we just got to witness chess boxing
now we have this tomorrow
another one slated it's just insane it's
insane it's coming your way tomorrow
Tuesday at 10 A.M Pacific 1 p.m Eastern
and 7 P.M Central European Time this is
unmissable you are not allowed to miss
the Carlson caruana SCC rematch Fabi has
been defying The Narrative playing some
incredible chess uh really after the
candidates he has been a man on a
mission in all time control so do not
miss tomorrow's match at 10 A.M Pacific
and also do not miss uh a another event
that's coming your way on December 13th
tomorrow which will be your chance to
play against sports legends Larry
Fitzgerald and Gordon Hayward not chess
not football and basketball you will
have a chance to play chess with them in
the first ever collab stream between
these two chess fans players will battle
Fitzgerald and Hayward in a rapid time
control Arena and all of the action will
be live streamed on Gordon's twitch
channel to become eligible and join the
arena on Game Day head on over to go dot
chess.com play Gordon go.chess.com play
Gordon and join Gordon haywardschess.com
club and of course he plays for uh I
wouldn't say my team but my hometown
team Charlotte Hornets so I love to see
Gordon playing chess drop X Glam Legends
in the chat for a direct link so that's
10 30 Pacific the Carlson match is at 10
Pacific I mean you can do whatever you
want tomorrow but it's going to be an
incredible day of Chess Jeffrey I'll
pass it back to you for your final
thoughts on what we saw today
yeah uh I mean well it just felt like
yet another day at the office for Hikaru
never really fell out of his grasp I
think
you know you could pinpoint one or two
of those five plus one games had Lavon
one it could have gone another way but
in the end yeah Hikaru moves on it's
been a pleasure as always you've been
grinding like crazy on this SEC so I
think I speak on behalf of everyone when
I say we fully appreciate your work and
thank you so much
well thank you Jeffrey I'm touched it's
always an honor and a pleasure to
commentate with you you offer incredible
insights and uh you know I'm just lucky
to have courtside seats to these matches
I can't wait for tomorrow's match which
I'll be bringing you together with Danny
wrench so Jeffrey thank you to you uh
thank you to everybody in the chat chat
with super Lively today supporting these
amazing players who put everything out
on the line and of course to our
wonderful chess.com crew for yet another
Flawless broadcast and on that note
ladies and Gentlemen We Wish You a
pleasant rest of your Monday join us
tomorrow at 10 A.M Pacific for Carlson
versus Carolina an epic rematch but for
now from the speed Chess Championship GM
Daniel nerdinski and GM Jeffrey Zhang
wishing you uh a great rest of your
evening we will see you tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]